THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON HEALTH WILL COME
TO ORDER. GOOD MORNING IN
RESPONSE TO THE COVERED
NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
AND EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
TO ENSURE THAT THE PUBLIC
CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS TO THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. I WOULD
MAKE NOTE IS THIS IS THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON HEALTH WE WILL BE
STRICTLY ENFORCING FACE
COVERING HERE IN THIS ROOM AS
WE ARE AN INDOOR GATHERING. TO
ALLOW PUBLIC ACCESS WITH
ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
INTO TWO HEARING ROOMS TO THE
EXTENT THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW. AND WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE ORVIS
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT. THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON OUR
COMMITTEES WEBSITE. IT WILL BE
DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN NOW I
WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS. EIGHT
FOUR FOUR TWO NINE ONE SIX
THREE SIX FOUR AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. THREE ZERO SEVEN. NINE
THREE THREE FIVE. AGAIN TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBERS.
844-291-6364 AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. THREE ZERO SEVEN NINE
THREE THREE FIVE FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES THEM WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE AND
OR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WHEN WE
MOVED THE PUBLIC COMMENT YOU'LL
BE PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR TO
DIAL ONE THEN ZERO FOUR SUPPORT.
AND OPPOSITION PRESS THIS ONLY
ONE TIME AND WAIT PATIENTLY FOR
AN OPERATOR TO SIGN YOU A LINE
NUMBER. THIS CAN BE A SHORT
WAIT. DID YOU RECEIVE YOUR LINE
NUMBER YOU'LL WAIT IN THE QUEUE
FOR THE MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR
LINE NUMBER AT THAT TIME YOU'LL
BE ON MUTED AND YOU ARE NOW
READY TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE.
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR
US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO
AVOID ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. YOU
MUST MUTE THE DEVICE YOU'RE
WATCHING THE HEARING ON. PRIOR
TO GIVING TESTIMONY OVER THE
PHONE. IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE
ARE ABLE TO HEAR FROM YOU AND
WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
AS CHAIR I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS
IS CUSTOMARY AND ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHOSE DISRUPTIVE MAY BE REMOVED
FROM THE REMOTE MEETING
SERVICE. OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
AND CONDUCTOR HEARINGS IN THIS
CLOSE A MANNER AS IS CUSTOMARY
THERE MAY BE SOMELAG TIMES FOR
PARTICIPANTS WERE ADJUSTING TO
THE NEW USE OF ON MY TECH TOOLS
OR TECHNOLOGIES. PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL AND PATIENTS SO THAT
ALL INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE
HEARD. EACH BILL BE INTRODUCED
BY ITS AUTHOR OR DESIGNEES.
WILL THEN HEAR TESTIMONY FROM
ONE OR TWO SUPPORTERS OF THE
BILL THAT THE NAME BY THE
AUTHOR FOR UP TO FOUR MINUTES.
AFTER THIS TESTIMONY IS GIVEN
DURING PUBLIC COMMENT. WE WILL
ASK ANY ADDITIONAL SUPPORTERS
TO IDENTIFY THEMSELVES BY NAME.
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION. WE
WILL THEN HEAR TESTIMONY FROM
ONE OR TWO OPPONENTS OF THE
BILL FOR UP TO FOUR MINUTES.
AFTER OPPOSITION TESTIMONY
DURING PUBLIC COMMENT WE'LL ASK
ANY ADDITIONAL OPPONENTS TO
IDENTIFY THEMSELVES AGAIN MY
NAME ORGANIZATION AND POSITION.
AGAIN EACH SIDE WILL BE GRANTED
A MAXIMUM OF FOUR MINUTES FOR
PRESENTATION. WHAT WE INTEND TO
HEAR FROM EVERYONE WHO WISHES
TO DECLARE TO POSITION ON EACH
BELL TO ENSURE THAT ALL BILLS
UNDER GENDER HEARD. I IS CHAIR
MAY HAVE TO CAP THE TOTAL TIME
FOR VERBAL TESTIMONY ON A BILL
GIVEN HEARING TIME CONSTRAINTS
COMMENTS ABOUT BILLS HEARD
TODAY CAN ALSO BE SENT TO THE
HEALTH COMMITTEE STAFF- WEBSITE
TO ENSURE THAT EVERYONE HAS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO WEIGH IN. TODAY
WE HAVE SEVENTEEN BILLS ON
TODAY'S AGENDA. SEVEN ITEMS ARE
ON A CONSENT CALENDAR THOSE ARE
ITEMS NUMBER ONE AB THIRTEEN
TWENTY SEVEN BY SOME EVERY
COUNTRY NORRIS ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN AB TWENTY ONE FIFTY SEVEN
BY SUMMER WOULD. ITEM NUMBER
EIGHT EIGHTY TWENTY ONE SIXTY
FOUR BY SOME MEMBERS
ROBERT RIVAS AND SALAS ITEM
NUMBER NINE AB TWENTY TWO FIFTY
THREE BY SOME EVER LOW. ITEM
NUMBER ELEVEN AB TWENTY THREE
HUNDRED BY SUMMER COOPER ITEM
NUMBER THIRTEEN. AB TWENTY FOUR
FIFTY BY SUMMER GRAYSON AND
ITEM NUMBER FOURTEEN AB TWENTY
FIVE TWENTY BY SOME MEMBER TO.
BEFORE WE CAN HEAR
PRESENTATIONS I WOULD ALSO MAKE
NOTE THAT- SENATOR MELENDEZ
WILL NOT BE INTENDED TODAY BUT
BEFORE WE HEAR PRESENTATIONS ON
THE BILL WE FIRST MUST
ESTABLISH A QUORUM. CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. PAN PAN
HERE GONZALEZ GONZALEZ HERE
GROW HER TARA. HER TITLE HERE
LEYVA. LEYVA HERE MELENDEZ
MITCHELL MORNING MORNING HERE
RUBIO. HERE ON. STONE KNOWS
THAT A QUORUM HAS BEEN
ESTABLISHED THAT ALSO MAKE NOTE
THAT WE HAVE NO MEMBERS
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY TODAY.
ALRIGHT SO WE WILL BEGIN BY
HEARING FROM OUR FIRST AUTHOR-
I SEE IS WELCOME IS A MEMBER
EGGMAN WE ARE SKILLED START
WITH ITEM NUMBER TWO. EIGHTY
NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX WELCOME.
WE BEGIN. WHAT OTHER ITEMS AND
AFTER A PAUSE. WE NEED TO DO IS
DO WE REALLY NEED TO DO THAT
AGAIN. OKAY WE NEED. TO WE NEED
TO KEEP THAT ARE NOW. OKAY OKAY
THE WORLD. OKAY WE'RE GONNA
PAUSE FOR A MOMENT WEIRD THAT
TO BE SURE THAT WE EVERYONE CAN
HEAR. SO SHE PATIENTS CENTER
EGGMAN. WELL WE ARE- WAITING- I
WOULD MAKE NOTE THAT- ONE
REMIND EVERYONE- WHEN YOU VOTE
PLEASE TURN ON YOUR MICROPHONE
DIED OR FIRST TO- CAPTURE YOUR
VOTES ACCURATELY ON THE
RECORDING THANK YOU. HE NICK
WERE A- YEAH. IF. WE CAN'T DO
ANYTHING.
SO YOU KNOW WE FOR
OUR TECHNICAL PEOPLE. TEXAS.
RIGHT NOW MY CHECK.
1-234-567-8910. RIGHT NOW OKAY.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE- SUMMER EGGMAN WELCOME.
ITEM NUMBER TWO EIGHTY NINETEEN
SEVENTY SIX. GOOD MORNING
SENATORS SAID MISTER CHAIR
THANK YOU ALL FOR BEING HERE
TODAY- I THINK IT'S ALL GONNA
GO SMOOTHLY AS I'M DRIVING DOWN
AND ALL THE LIGHTS TURN GREEN
ALL THE WAY DOWN SO I TAKE THAT
AS A GOOD SIGN FOR ALL OF US
HERE TODAY. AT TODAY I'M HERE
TO PRESENT AB NINETEEN SEVENTY
SIX WHICH UPDATES AND EXPAND
SOME ASPECTS OF LAURA'S LAW
WENT HOME AGAIN WANT TO START
BY THANKING THE CHAIR FOR
HEARING THIS BILL TODAY AND
ALSO GLADLY ACCEPTING THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE AMENDMENT
TO AT THE DELAY IMPLEMENTATION
UNTIL JULY TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
THIS IS THE SECOND BILL I
INTRODUCED THIS YEAR AS PART OF
MY MENTAL HEALTH PACKAGE WELL
BEFORE THE PANDEMIC WE ALREADY
HAD A PANDEMIC ON OUR STREETS.
DEALING WITH HOMELESSNESS AND
MENTAL HEALTH. AND THIS IS ONE
STEP OF MY THAT MAKING MY
QUESTION ALL OF OUR QUEST TO
TRY TO ADDRESS THIS. ASSISTED
OUTPATIENT TREATMENT OR LAURA'S
LAW IT'S AN EVIDENCE BASED
COMMUNITY BASED PROGRAM THAT
PROVIDES TREATMENTS. TO THOSE
WHO OTHERWISE MAY BE UNABLE TO
ACCESS COMMITTEE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES VOLUNTARILY. DUE TO
THEIR SEVERE MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES. THIS BILL WOULD EXPAND
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF. ASSISTED
OUTPATIENT TREATMENT STATEWIDE
WHILE STILL PROVIDING LOCAL
CONTROL THROUGH THE
FLEXIBILITY. TO ALLOW COUNTIES
TO OPT OUT BY LOCAL BOARDS. AND
THIS WILL ALSO ALLOW COUNTY
THAT MIGHT BE SMALLER TO
COLLABORATE WITH EACH OTHER- AS
THEY AS THEY MOVE TOWARDS
IMPLEMENTATION. AS WELL AS
REPEALING THE SUNSET DATE.
AFTER EIGHTEEN YEARS OF THIS
BEING IMPLEMENTED WE FEEL LIKE
IT IS AND AGAIN EVIDENCE BASED
HAS BEEN IN EXISTENCE EIGHTEEN
YEARS. AND WHILE WE'RE REMOVING
A SUNSET DATE. DISTILLING TO BE
REPORT DONE TO THE STATE EVERY
SINGLE YEAR. NONE OF US ARE
STRAIN TO THE MENTAL HEALTH
CONDITIONS THAT ARE IN OUR
STATE IN OUR COUNTRY THAT
PLAGUE OUR STREETS AND THE
FAMILIES THAT WE KNOW ARE
BEHIND EVERY PERSON. THAT WE
SEE OUT THERE. THIS WEEK THE
STATE AUDITOR RELEASED A- AUDIT
ON LPS THAT WE'VE ALL BEEN
ANTICIPATING FOR MONTHS I WOULD
LIKE TO SEE IT SOONER BUT WE'RE
VERY GRATEFUL THAT IT. IS
ARRIVE ANNA AND I AND IT HAS GO
EVEN FOR THAN THIS BILL DOES
AND I AM CERTAINLY SUPPORTIVE
OF THAT. BUT WE HAVE THIS BILL
IN FRONT OF US TODAY AND AS YOU
ALL KNOW WHEN WE GET TO TE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS OF
REVIEWING AND BOUGHT IT THAT
MAY TAKE MONTHS HERE'S- A TIME
RIGHT NOW WE HAVE SOMETHING IN
FRONT OF US THAT WILL ACT AS
ONE MORE TOOL IN THE TOOLBOX.
DO I THINK ASSISTED APERTURE
TREATMENT SHOULD BE IMPLEMENTED
STATEWIDE YES I DO BUT THIS
PROVIDES A FIRST STEP THAT
CONTINUES TO WRITE LOCAL
CONTROL. TO COUNTIES- IF WE
DECIDE TO HAVE MORE CHANGES
LATER WE CAN CERTAINLY DO THAT.
THIS BILL ALSO. MAKE SURE THAT
NO FUNDS THAT ARE CURRENTLY USE
FOR OTHER PROGRAMS ARE DEFERRED
TO BE ABLE TO USE FOR THIS.
ESPECIALLY THOSE DEALING WITH
CHILDREN. THAT EXPANDING LOWERS
LAW WOULD HOPEFULLY MEET
EARLIER INTERVENTION. AS WE
KNOW THAT WHEN PEOPLE ACTUALLY
GET TO THE POINT WHERE THEY
HAVE TO BE HELD AGAINST THEIR
WILL IT IS REACHED A CRISIS
POINT WE KNOW THE COST OF
PEOPLE CIRCLING IN AND OUT OF
OUR EMERGENCY ROOMS IN OUR
JAILS BEHIND MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES WE KNOW THIS IS AN
EFFECTIVE IMPLEMENTATION- THEN
WE KNOW THAT. POTENTIALLY LOWER
WILCOX WITH HIS BILL IS NAMED
AFTER WOULD STILL BE ALIVE WITH
US TODAY IF THIS TREATMENT HAD
BEEN IN PLACE- AGAIN THIS IS A
ROBUST PROGRAM EVERY MEMBER
HERE WITH THE EXCEPTION OF THAT
DOCTOR PAN AND THE VICE CHAIR
ALREADY HAVE THIS PROGRAM IN
THEIR COUNTIES- IMAGINE I'M
SURE YOU STILL SEE THE PROBLEMS
ON YOUR STREETS IMAGINE WHAT IT
WOULD BE IF THEY DIDN'T HAVE
THIS THIS TOOL AS WELL- WE
STILL HAVE A LOT MORE WORK TO
DO. BUT THIS IS ONE STEP AND I
WILL RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE AFTER HOPEFULLY A YEAH
A DISCUSSION AND WITH ME TODAY
IS RENTAL HAGAR FROM THE
CALIFORNIA PSYCHIATRIC
ASSOCIATION AND MISTER NICK
WILCOX THE FATHER OF NORMAL
**** THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU VERY MUCH IS A VERY EGGMAN-
DUE TO- WE'RE NOT GONNA MOVE ON
TO BE ABLE TO TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT DUE TO CONSTRAINTS
REGARDING THE LENGTH OF
HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS AND CLEAN
RECALLS. AS CHAIR I AM ISSUING
TIME LIMIT OF A MAXIMUM FOUR
MINUTES FOR ON THE TESTIMONY
FOR EACH SIDE- ALL OTHERS
WISHING TO TESTIFY MUST LIMIT
THEIR COMMENTS HERE NAME
AFFILIATION POSITION ON THE
MEASURES SO- AGAIN LET'S BEGIN
WITH- MISTER RANDALL HAGER FROM
THE CALIFORNIA PSYCHIATRIC
ASSOCIATION FOLLOWED BY NICK
WILCOX FATHER FLORA WILCOX SO-
MODERATOR. PLEASE FROM IT MR
HAGAR TO BEGIN TESTIMONY. OKAY
STILL. THE CARD. MODERATOR ARE%
YOU ABLE TO GET MR HAGAR ON THE
PHONE ON THE LINE. ALL RIGHT-
APOLOGIZE WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO
TAKE THE POSSIBLE WE TRY TO
SORT OUT. OKAY OKAY OKAY ALL
RIGHT FIVE DAYS WE GOT TO TAKE
A PAUSE WELL WE SORT OUT A
TECHNICAL ISSUE AGAIN. TWENTY
THREE CENTS I MEAN I'M ON THE
LINE IS THIS A MISTAKE ARE. IS
ON THE LINE CAN YOU HEAR ME YES
I CAN HEAR YOU CAN YOU HEAR ME
THIS IS THE CHAIR CAN YOU
PLEASE IDENTIFY YOURSELF FIRST
PLEASE. SEE HERE. SO HE SAT
HERE THIS IS NICOLE CUT SOME
ALSO ON THE LINE OKAY THANK YOU.
WE'RE GOING TO PUT A PLAGUE OF
MAKING UP BECAUSE UNLESS YOU
CAN INDICATE THAT YOU CAN HEAR
ME. THIS IS THE CHAIR. OKAY WE
ARE SORRY I CAN HEAR YOU OKAY
IS MR HAGAR ON AS WELL. BRANDO
HAGAR. OKAY HI. WE A TECHNICAL
ISSUE YEAH OKAY RIGHT NOW I'M
GONNA ASK BUT YOU JUST HOLD FOR
A MOMENT I'M GETTING CLEARANCE
FROM THE STAFF TO BE SURE THAT.
TESTIMONY OKAY I'M TOLD TO HOLD.
OKAY IS ON A LOT OF. YES I CAN
HEAR YEARS WELL. THERE'S THAT'S
ME OKAY ECHOING ALL RIGHT SO
LONG AS YOU'RE ON THE HOLD HERE
WHILE WE SORT OF TECHNICAL
ISSUE.
ALRIGHT SO WE ARE GOING
TO RECESS THIS HEARING OF THE
COMMITTEE ON HEALTH FOR TWENTY
MINUTES AS WE RESOLVE OUR
TECHNICAL ISSUES TO APOLOGIZE.
SO WE WILL RECONVENE. AT TEN
FIFTY THANK YOU.
THE SENATE CAN
BE A HELPFUL COME BACK TO ORDER
GOOD AFTERNOON IN RESPONSE TO
THE COVERT NINETEEN OVER TO SEE
AN TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
LEGISLATORS EMPLOYEES WE MUST
LIMIT NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS
AND IT HERE TO SOCIAL
DISTANCING AND FACE COVERING
GUIDELINES. IN COMPLIANCE WITH
THOSE ORDERS THE SENATE HAS
MADE NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS IN
NORMAL PRACTICES IN ORDER TO
ENSURE THAT THE PUBLIC
CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS TO THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. TO ALLOW
PUBLIC ACCESS WITH ADMITTED
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO
HEARING ROOMS TO THE EXTENT
THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW. AND WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE ORVIS
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT. THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON A COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. IT WILL BE DISPLAYED
ON THE SCREEN AND I WILL
ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS EIGHT
FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE ONE SIX
THREE SIX FOUR AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS THREE OH SEVEN. NINE
THREE THREE FIVE AGAIN THE
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS EIGHT
FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE ONE SIX
THREE SIX FOUR AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS THREE ZERO SEVEN. NINE
THREE THREE FIVE FOR DETAILED
AND ON HOW THE TELECONFERENCES
THEM WORKS PLEASE REFER TO THE
SENATE. AND OR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. WHEN WE MOVE THE
PUBLIC COMMENT YOU'LL BE
PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR TO DIAL
ONE THEN ZERO FOR SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION. PRESS THIS ONLY ONE
TIME AND WAIT PATIENTLY FOR AN
OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A. LINE
NUMBER THIS CAN BE A SHORT WAIT.
ONCE YOU RE YOUR LAW NUMBER
YOU'LL IN THE QUEUE FOR THE
MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR LINE
NUMBER. AT THAT TIME YOU'LL BE
A MUTED AND YOU ARE NOW READY
TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE.
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR
YOU. ACTUALLY PLEASE NOTE THAT
ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY AND AVOID ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK. YOU MUST MUTE THE
DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT IS
IMPORTANT WE HEAR FROM YOU WE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE. AS
CHAIR I WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM
DURING THE HEARING AS IS
CUSTOMARY AND ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHOSE DISRUPTIVE MAY BE REMOVED
FROM THE REMOTE MEETING
SERVICE. OR HAVE DRUG
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINED HEARING PROCESS AND
CONDUCTOR HEARINGS IN THIS
CLOSE. TO THE SAME MANNER AS IS
CUSTOMARY THERE MAY BE SOME LAG
TIMES FOR PARTICIPANTS TO
ADJUSTING TO THE NEW USE OF
ONLINE TOOLS OR TECHNOLOGIES.
PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL AND
PATIENT SO THAT ALL INTERESTED
PARTIES CAN BE HEARD. EACH BILL
WILL BE INTRODUCED BY ITS
AUTHOR DESIGNEES WE WILL THEN
HEAR TESTIMONY FROM ONE OR TWO
SUPPORTERS OF THE BILL THAT'S
THE NIGHT BY THE AUTHOR FOR UP
TO FOUR MINUTES. AFTER THIS%
TESTIMONY DURING PUBLIC COMMENT
WE'LL ASK ANY ADDITIONAL
SUPPORTERS TURNED IN A FIRE
THEMSELVES BY THEIR NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION. BILL
THEN HEAR TESTIMONY FROM ONE OR
TWO OPPONENTS OF THE BILL FOR
UP TO FOUR MINUTES AFTER
OPPOSITION TESTIMONY DURING
PUBLIC COMMENT. WE WILL ASK ANY
ADDITIONAL OPPONENTS TO
IDENTIFY THEMSELVES BY NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION.
AGAIN EACH SIDE WE GRANTED A
MAXIMUM OF FOUR MINUTES FOR
PRESENTATION. BUT WE DO INTEND
TO HEAR FROM EVERYONE WHO
WISHES TO CLEAR TO POSITION ON
EACH BILL. TO ENSURE THAT ALL
THE BILL'SUNDER GENDER HEARD.
I MAY AS CHAIR HAVE THE CAP THE
TOTAL TIME FOR VERBAL TESTIMONY
ON THE BILL GIVEN HEARING
TIMING CONSTRAINTS. COMMENTS
ABOUT BILLS HEARD TODAY CAN BE
SENT TO THE HEALTH COMMITTEE
STAFF OUR WEBSITE TO ENSURE
THAT EVERYONE HAS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO EXPRESS THEIR-
VIEWS AND OPINIONS. TO WE DO
HAVE A STILL SEVENTEEN BILLS ON
TODAY'S AGENDA. INCLUDING SEVEN
BILLS THAT ARE ON CONSENT. WE
HAVE ESTABLISHED A QUORUM AT
THE INITIATION OF THIS HEARING
PRIOR TO OUR RECESS. SO THE
COURT THE COURT HAS BEEN
ESTABLISHED. SO WITH THAT- WE
WILL RESUME THE HEARING WITH
OUR FIRST. PRESENTATION AT ITEM
NUMBER TWO COMMA. THAT. EIGHTY
SEVENTY SIX BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
EGGMAN AND- SO MEMBERS YOU'RE
PREPARED PLANS PERCENT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND- GOOD
AFTERNOON- CHAIR PAN AND
SENATORS I'M HERE TODAY TO
PRESENT AB NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX
WHICH UPDATES AND EXPERIENCE
SOME ASPECT OF LAURA'S LAW I
WANT TO THANK THE CHAIR OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE AMENDMENTS
AND I AM GLAD TO ACCEPT THEM-
DELAYING THE IMPLEMENTATION
UNTIL JULY OF TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. THIS IS THE SECOND BILL I
INTRODUCED THIS YEAR ABOUT
RESPONDING TO THE R. DUAL
CRISIS OF MENTAL HEALTH AND
HOMELESSNESS THIS IS ONE PART
OF THAT THAT PACKAGE. AND THIS
WAS BEFORE COVERT BECAUSE WE
KNOW EVEN THOUGH WE HAVE A
PANDEMIC WE'VE HAD A PANDEMIC
IN THE STREETS FOR SOMETIME NOW
DEALING WITH. A MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES AND HOMELESSNESS THAT
HAS REACHED A CRISIS LEVEL.
ASSISTED OUTPATIENT TREATMENT
IS AN EVIDENCE BASED COMMUNITY
BASED PROGRAM THAT PROVIDES
TREATMENTS TO THOSE WHO ARE
UNABLE. TO PROVIDE TAXES
COMMUNITY MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES VOLUNTARILY OFTEN DUE
TO THEIR MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES.
THIS BILL WOULD EXPAND THE
IMPLEMENTATION STATEWIDE BUT
STILL PROVIDING FLEXIBILITY FOR
LOCAL COUNTIES TO BE ABLE TO
OPT OUT. AB NINETEEN SEVENTY
SIX WILL ALSO ALLOW COUNTY IS
THE OPTION TO COLLABORATE WITH
EACH OTHER ON IMPLEMENTATION-
AFTER EIGHT THIS BILL ALSO
REMOVES A SUNSET DATE AND WE
FEEL THAT AFTER EIGHTEEN YEARS
OF AN EVIDENCE BASED PROGRAM.
IT'S TIME TO REMOVE THE SUNSET
DATE AND WE ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
THERE ARE STILL REPORTS THAT
ARE REQUIRED EVERY SINGLE YEAR
AS IT IS DURING THESE UNCERTAIN
TIMES WE'VE ALSO SAID THAT THIS
BILL. AT IMPLEMENTING A O. T.
MAY NOT TAKE FROM OTHER
PROGRAMS THAT ARE ALREADY BEING
FUNDED. EARLIER THIS WEEK- THE
STATE UNDER RE RELEASING LPS
REPORT THAT WE'VE ALL BEEN
ANTICIPATING. AND WHILE THE LPS
REPORT STATES. AOTI SHE BE IN
STATEWIDE AND WELL I AGREE WITH
THAT. I THINK WE SHOULD MOVE
FORWARD WITH WHERE WE ARE HERE
TODAY TO BE ABLE TO IMPLEMENT
AS LET COUNTIES BEGIN TO GET
READY AND THEN WE CAN CONTINUE.
THE TALK ABOUT THE OUT ITS
REPORT AS WE GO FOR. BUT IS NOT
EXCUSE ME TO PASS WHAT WE HAVE
IN FRONT OF US. RIGHT NOW. THE
SO IT FEELS LIKE I'VE BEEN UP
HERE ALL MORNING- AND SO I WILL
NOW ASK OUR WITNESSES TO BE
ABLE TO SPEAK ON THIS PROGRAM
AND WITH US HERE TODAY WE HAVE
RENTAL HAGAR FROM THEM AND
PSYCHIATRIC ASSOCIATION AS WELL
AS NICK WILCOX HIS DAUGHTER
LARA FROM HOME THIS BILL IS
NAMED WHO WAS WHO WAS KILLED
ALMOST TWENTY YEARS AGO- SO
THANK THEM FOR THEIR
PARTICIPATION TODAY AND- THE-
YIELD THE FLOOR. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AS A MEMBER EGGMAN- WE'RE
NOW GOING TO MOVE ON TO. ANYONE
TEST ONE TO TEST FIND SUPPORT
DUE TO CONSTRAINTS REGARDING
THE LENGTH OF HEARINGS
TECHNOLOGY CONSIDERATIONS IN
CLEANING PROTOCOLS THE-
COMMITTEE CHAIR IS INSTITUTING
A FOUR MINUTE TIME LIMIT. FOR
EACH SIDE. ALL OTHERS WISHING
TO TESTIFY MUST LIMITED COMMON
SURNAME AFFILIATION AND
POSITION ON THE MEASURES SO WE
WILL BEGIN WITH. OUR TWO
WITNESSES. WHO ARE TESTIFYING
IN SUPPORT FIRST- RANDALL HAGER
FROM THE CALIFORNIA PSYCHIATRIC
ASSOCIATION FOLLOWED BY. NICK
WILCOX ON THE TO DO SO-
MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE-
FIRST- PERMIT THIS TO WITNESSES
STARTING WITH MR HAGAR TO
PRESENT. SHARE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I AM
RANDALL PICKER- I DO REPRESENT
THE CALIFORNIA PSYCHE
ASSOCIATION THE SPONSORS OF
THIS JUST REAL QUICKLY TO KIND
OF REMIND US ABOUT WHAT
ASSISTED OUTPATIENT TREATMENT
IS A PROGRAM THAT'S BASICALLY
COURT SUPERVISED INTENSIVE
TREATMENT IT'S MEANT FOR A
SMALL GROUP OF INDIVIDUALS. WHO
TYPICALLY LACK INSIGHT- BAY MAY
RECESSES BECAUSE OF THAT A
REFUSE OR BE ABLE BECAUSE
THEY'RE TOO SICK TO ACTUALLY
COMPLY WITH TREATMENT BECAUSE
OF THAT- IT'S NOT SURPRISING
THEY GET ARRESTED THEY HAVE
HOSPITALIZATIONS THEY MAY NEED
HE ALSO ENGAGE IN A PRESS FOR
ACTS OF VIOLENCE AND THIS IS A
REVOLVING DOOR PATTERN FOR THEM
BASED ON RESEARCH THIS KIND OF
PROGRAM SHOWS YOU CAN GET VERY
GOOD OUTCOMES UNDER TWO
CONDITIONS. ONE IS THAT IF YOU
TREAT PEOPLE PSYCHOTIC
DISORDERS THAT'S ONE UP FOR AT
LEAST SIX MONTHS YOU CAN REDUCE
HOSPITALIZATIONS WRAPS
SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCE VIOLENCE-
THEY ALSO RETAIN STABLE HOUSING
IN AN ASSISTED OUTPATIENT
PROGRAM I'M PROBABLY JUST AS
IMPORTANT AS ANYTHING ELSE IF
NOT MORE SO BEAR MEDICATION
COMPLIANCE. IN THE PROGRAM THE
STATUTE HAS SUBSTANTIAL
PROCEDURAL DUE PROCESS- THESE
INDIVIDUALS OFTEN FACE A CHOICE
WHEN ASSISTED OUTPATIENT
TREATMENT IS AVAILABLE IT'S AN
ALTERNATIVE TO JAIL POSSIBLY
PRISON BUT CERTAINLY JAIL OR
HOSPITALIZATION IT IS A COURT
SUPERVISED PROGRAM IS A SAD- IN
THE LEAST RESTRICTIVE SETTING
ONCE YOU'RE DONE WITH THE COURT
PROCESS YOU GET TO GO HOME AND
SLEEP IN YOUR OWN BED AT NIGHT
IT IS A COMMUNITY BASED
PROGRAM. AND AS I SAID IT HAS-
VERY REMARKABLE AND SOMETIMES
DRAMATIC RESULTS FOR PEOPLE
IT'S BEEN DEMONSTRATED FOR OVER
EIGHTEEN YEARS IT IS DESERVING-
STATEWIDE APPLICATION AND NOW
WE HAVE A VERY POWERFUL-
SENTIMENTS ON THE PART OF THE-
AUDITOR. THAT THE SHOULD GHOST
EVEN THOUGH NOT WHAT WE HAD SHE
WITH THIS WE BELIEVE IT'S VERY
CONSISTENT WITH THAT PART OF
THE AUDITOR'S REPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- I
UNDERSTAND MISTER WILCOX AND
FOURTEEN IS NOT CALLED BACK BUT
MODERATELY PLEASE CHECK AGAIN
TO SEE IF MISTER WILLCOX IS
AVAILABLE TO TESTIFY. YEAH I AM
ON THE LINE THANK YOU WELCOME.
PLEASE BEGIN. OKAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH A GOOD AFTERNOON I
HAD ORIGINALLY WRITTEN GOOD
MORNING BUT IT IS AFTERNOON- MY
NAME IS NICOLE COCCI I'M
CALLING IN THIS MORNING AND I
IN SUPPORT OF AB NINETEEN
SEVENTY SIX- BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
HOW SUSAN EGGMAN- THIS STILL
REMOTE THE SUNSET CLAUSE FROM
LARS VON THE- COUNTIES. TO
IMPLEMENT THE LAW UNLESS THEY
AFFIRMATIVELY OPT OUT. MY WIFE
AMANDA AND I BEEN AND IN THIS
ISSUE SINCE TWO THOUSAND ONE.
WHEN AB FOURTEEN TWENTY ONE WAS
FIRST UNDER CONSIDERATION IN
THAT YEAR. OUR DAUGHTER LAURA
WAS A VICTIM IN A RAMPAGE
SHOOTING PERPETRATED BY A MAN
WITH SEVERE UNTREATED MENTAL
ILLNESS. WE UNDERSTOOD EARLY
THAT MANY WITH SEVERE MENTAL
ILLNESS DO NOT RECOGNIZE OR
ACKNOWLEDGE THEIR CONDITION
THEREFORE DO NOT ENGAGE IN
TREATMENT. LARGE LAW WAS AN
ATTEMPT TO CREATE A LEGAL
STRUCTURE AND A TREATMENT
PROGRAM TO ENGAGE SUCH
INDIVIDUALS. WE ENCOUNTER
STRONG OPPOSITION AT THAT TIME
IN ORDER TO MOVE THE ISSUE
FORWARD ASSEMBLY MEMBER HELEN
THOMPSON. ORIGINAL AUTHOR OF
THE FOURTEEN TWENTY ONE AGREED
TO A FIVE YEAR SUNSET CLAUSE IN
TWO THOUSAND TWO. WHEN OUR OWN
COUNTY- WHICH IS NEVADA COUNTY
WAS THE FIRST TO FULLY
IMPLEMENT LARGE LAW IN TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHT SINCE THEN
MANY COUNTY SO FOLLOWED SUIT
NOW OVER HALF OF. BUT IT CAN
COUNTIES THAT HAVE IMPLEMENTED
THE LAW. THE LEGISLATURE HAS
EXTENDED THE SUNSET ON THREE
SEPARATE OCCASIONS SINCE THAT
TIME. THE DIRE CONSEQUENCES OF
THE LOG THEIR OPPONENT'S
PREDICTED AT THE OUTSET HAVE
NOT MATERIALIZED. IN OUR COUNTY
THE OUTCOMES HAVE BEEN BETTER
THAN WE HAD EVER ENVISIONED THE
PRODUCTIONS AND
HOSPITALIZATIONS INCARCERATION
AND HOMELESS. THE COURT ORDER
ITSELF HAS NOT BEEN UTILIZED AS
FREQUENTLY AS WE HAD EXPECTED
MISTER. FANTASTIC ARTICLE
SHORTLY. HAS THAT. IS IT IN
OVER 50% OF CASES CORRIDORS ARE
ARE UNNECESSARY AND PEOPLE
ENGAGING TREATMENT VOLUNTARILY
AFTER INTERACTION WITH THE
JUDGE. THIS IS EXACTLY WHAT WE
HAD HOPED FOR AFTER ALL THE
GOAL OF MOORE'S LAW IS NOT TO
BE PUNITIVE BUT TO ENGAGE
PEOPLE AND LONG TERM TREATMENT
SO THAT THEY MAY START ON THE
ROAD TO RECOVERY. WE BELIEVE
THAT LEARNING LONG HAS NOW
PROVEN AND THE TIME IS COME TO
MAKE IT PERMANENT AND MAKE IT
AVAILABLE TO YOU CAN MORE
CALIFORNIANS. PROVIDING QUALITY
MENTAL HEALTH CARE IS THE
HUMANE THING TO DO A CUTS AND
EASIER AT BEST INTEREST TO SIGN.
ON MULTIPLE OCCASIONS OVER THE
LAST FIFTEEN YEARS PEOPLE HAVE
APPROACHED AMANDA NINE
INSTRUMENT CUTS AND THEN ASKING
DENTAL RECORDS PLEASE. I WILL
FINISH AND- THEY IT APPROACHED
US AND THANKED US AND SAID THAT
WITHOUT IT THEIR LOVED ONES
WOULD NO LONGER BE ALIVE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU SORRY AND WHAT WHAT
WE'LL GET SOME ADDITIONAL TIME
TO THE OPPOSITION IF THEY WISH
TO USE IT. ALL RIGHT- ARE THERE
OTHER WITNESSES WHO ARE- WHICH
TO TEST EXPRESS THEIR SUPPORT-
PLEASE. THE IT WOULD BE NAY
AFFILIATION AND POSITION FOR A
START HERE WITH ANY WITNESSES
HERE IN THE CHAMBER. I DO NOT
SEE ANY IN THE GALLERY ARE
THERE ANY AND- ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. I DON'T SEE ANYONE WILL
NOW MOVE ON TO WITNESSES
WAITING TO TESTIFY VIA
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS MODERATOR
IF YOU WOULD PLEASE PROPERTY
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF AB NINETEEN
SEVENTY SIX. WE WILL BEGIN. AND
IF YOU CAN INDICATE TO ME FIRST
HOW MANY UP THE TOTAL NUMBER OF
PEOPLE WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. JERRY YOU HAVE FOUR
PEOPLE IN SUPPORT. OKAY THEY
CAN GO AHEAD AND BEGIN. YES SIR
LINE ONE THIRTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIRMAN CATION BRYANT'S ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA'S
DOWNTOWN ASSOCIATION AND THE
DOWNTOWN SACRAMENTO PARTNERSHIP
WE ARE SUPPORTING THE BILL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
NEXT WITNESS. LINE ONE FORTY TO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
KELLY YET ON BEHALF OF THAT ARE
HELD IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANK
WITNESS. LINE ONE FORTY SIX.
GOOD AFTERNOON BARBARA LEVER
WITH THE STEINBERG INSTITUTE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. NINE ONE FORTY
EIGHT. ERIN RILEY ON BEHALF OF
THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL WE ARE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. ARE THERE
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES AND
ACTUALLY MODERATE TO YOU PLEASE
REPEAT THE ACTUAL INSTRUCTIONS
FOR PEOPLE TO ENSURE THAT WE'RE
NOT HAVING ANYONE WHO MAY NOT.
KNOW HOW TO- ENTERED THE Q.
THIRTY PLEASE REPEAT THOSE
INSTRUCTIONS AND LET'S CHECK
THE LINE TO BE SURE WE'VE HEARD
FROM ALL THE SUPPORTERS ON THIS
BILL. AND LADIES AND GENTLEMAN
ON THE PHONE NINE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE. ZERO ON YOUR PHONE. ONE
ZERO FOR ANY- QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS SO THIS IN SUPPORT OF
AB NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX. OKAY
IF THERE'S NO OTHER WITNESSES
AND SUPPORT ON THE LINE. EFFORT
YOU HAVE LINE ONE FORTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD RIGHT. IN LINE
ONE FORTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
AMANDA LEVY CALIFORNIA'S
PSYCHOLOGICAL ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU. LINE ONE
FORTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS DANNY
OFFER WITH BLACKMUN VISORS
REPRESENTING THE NATIONAL
ALLIANCE ON MENTAL ILLNESS ALSO
KNOWN AS NOT IN CALIFORNIA
SUPPORT THANKS. THANK YOU. WHY
LINE ONE THIRTY TO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. AUTHORITY TO BE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. EN ROUTE FINAL LINE
AND SUPPORT WILL COME FROM ONE
SIXTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO.
PLEASE CHECK IF THAT PERSON
STILL ON THE LINE. NINE ONE
SIXTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I
APOLOGIZE I NINETY OP. SELECT
RIGHT WILK OKAY ANY OTHER-
WITNESSES WISHING TO TESTIFY
EXPRESS THEIR SUPPORT AT THIS
TIME. THERE ARE NO ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES SIR OKAY THANKS VERY
MUCH MODERATOR WE WILL NOW MOVE
TO THE OPPOSITION- THE- TOOK
THE FIRES N OPPOSITION TO LEAD
OPPOSITION ARE ELLO CAR
ALTHOUGH THE COUNTY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA. AND CURTIS CHILD
WITH DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA MODERATE YOU TO
PLEASE BRING THEM ON THE LINE
STARTING WITH ELLA DORADO AND
DATE MADE. BEGIN THEIR
TESTIMONY. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
EIGHT THANK YOU HONORABLE
MEMBERS I'M ELLIE OKAY APPLE
THE DIRECTOR OF GOVERNMENT
AFFAIRS FOR THE COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION THE LPS AUDIT
REFERENCE PREVIOUSLY LOOKED AT
INVOLUNTARY SERVICES ARE
OPPOSITION AB NINETEEN SEVENTY
SIX IS REALLY BASED ON CONCERNS
RELATED TO THE IMPACT THE
BILL'S GOING TO HAVE A
VOLUNTARY COMMUNITY BASED
HEALTH SERVICES UNDER THEM
FRONT IN THE QUIRK AND THEY'LL
ACT THE PUBLIC MENTAL HEALTH
DELIVERY SYSTEM WAS CREATED TO
ENSURE VULNERABLE INDIVIDUALS
WITH MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS HAVE
ACTED THE LEAST RESTRICTIVE.
CLIENT CENTERED SERVICES THAT
PROMOTE SELF DETERMINATION AND
PERSONAL RIGHT THESE VALUES OF
THE PUBLIC MENTAL HEALTH
SYSTEMS ARE REFLECTED IN THE
EXISTING AIR Q. ROLE WHICH HOLD
THAT THIS COURSE OF SERVICE A
COUNTY OPTION ADOPTED ONLY
AFTER A COMPREHENSIVE REVIEW OF
THE IMPACT ADOPTING THIS
PROGRAM CURRENTLY REQUIRES A
COUNTY HIS BELLY WITH THE
IMPACT ON VOLUNTARY SERVICES
FOR ADULTS AND ANY SERVICES FOR
CHILDREN ONLY AFTER A COUNTY
DEMONSTRATE NO ADVERSE IMPACT
ON THE LEAST RESTRICTIVE
SERVICES. KENNY COUNTY INTO
PROVIDING A KEY AB NINETEEN
SEVENTY SIX IN THIS PROCESS AND
WOULD ALLOW IN OUR COULD WE'RE
CONCERNED THAT IT WOULD ALLOW
HIM POLITICAL DYNAMICS IT TAKE
TO BE TAKEN INTO ACCOUNT FIRST
OF THE AFOREMENTIONED
COMPREHENSIVE EVALUATION
ADDITIONALLY UNDER THE CURRENT
BUDGET KLEIN NETWORK COMPANIES
ARE EXPECTED TO SEE A ONE
BILLION DOLLAR DROP IN REVENUE
THAT THE FADING REDUCTIONS IN
SERVICES AND PROGRAMS ACROSS
THE STATE. THIS IS ABSOLUTELY
THE WRONG KIND OF PRESSURE
COUNTY IMPLEMENTED NEW PROGRAM
OR EXPAND ON AN EXISTING ONE
COUNTIES ARE ALREADY FEELING
THE PRESSURE TO SERVE THE
ADDITIONAL ONE POINT TWO
MILLION NEW MEDI CAL
BENEFICIARIES WHILE OUR REVENUE
SEARCHES ARE PLUMMETING RIGHT
NOW THE UPTAKE OF AOKI IS
WORKING IN A MANNER THAT IT
NEEDS TO WORK IN A REPORT. THAT
ENVIRONMENT AND UNFORTUNATELY
AB THAT SEVENTY SIX NOTHING TO
ADDRESS. THE REAL. SENDING A-
WHICH IS THE LACK REPORT.
BECAUSE OF THE KERN BUDGET. IN
CONCERN WITH THE BIT THAT THIS
MAKE. OUR ABILITY TO PROVIDE
SERVICES IN THE LEAST
RESTRICTIVE SETTING. HE A
STRONGLY URGES HEALTH COMMITTEE.
NO ON THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK THANK YOU OF NEXT WHAT
THE STATUS OF IS MISTER CHILD.
GOOD AFTERNOON DOCTOR BILLION
AND MEMBERS OF- OF THE
COMMITTEE WE AGREE WITH AND
CHILLING IN THE TESTIMONY OF
OUR COLLEAGUE FROM OTHER COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION WE HAD INITIALLY
HAS AN OPPOSING COMMANDED
POSITION ON BILL FIRST WE
BELIEVE THAT IN THE EVENT THAT.
A MULTI COUNTY PROGRAMS THAT
WOULD NOW BE AUTHORIZED
SERVICES SHOULD BE PROVIDED
WHERE THE RECIPIENT RESIDES OR
IN THE IN AN AREA READILY
ACCESSIBLE TO THE SERVICES AND
THAT THE BILL WOULD NEED TO
REFLECT THAT- SECOND WE BELIEVE
THAT THIS BILL HASN'T BEEN A
SIGNIFICANT CHANGE IN THE
NATURE OF THE PROGRAM FROM-
FROM BEING AN OPTIONAL TO A
MANDATORY PROGRAM. AND BY
ALLOWING THE MULTI COUNTY
ADMINISTRATION AND SERVICE
DELIVERY SO WE THINK IT WOULD
BE APPROPRIATE- TO CONTINUE TO
HAVE A SUNSET REMAIN IN THE ACT
SO THAT THE IMPACT OF THIS
REVISED PROGRAM CAN BE
EVALUATED UNDER THAT NEW
STRUCTURE AND BE SUBJECT TO
FURTHER EVALUATION. HOWEVER
WITH THE RELEASE OF THE STATE
AUDITOR'S AUDIT OF THE LPS
SYSTEM THIS WEEK WE'RE NOW
OPPOSED TO THE BILL- THE
AUDITOR'S FINDING MADE CLEAR
THAT THE STATE SHOULD NOT BE
MAKING IT EASIER TO FORCE
MENTALLY ILL. CALIFORNIANS IN
THE TREATMENT RATHER SHOULD BE
OUR BALL TREATMENT AND THE
DELAY OF SIR. THE AUDITOR'S
SOME IN WHERE THAT IVOLUNTARY-
TREAT WHICH SHOULD NOT BE
EXPANDED AND SHE ANALYZE VIDEO
TV- WITHIN THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS SO WE BELIEVE
THAT THE OTHERS-
RECOMMENDATIONS- DESERVE SOME
CAREFUL EVALUATION WITHIN THE
CONTEXT OF THE ENTIRE MENTAL
HEALTH LITTLE EVERY SYSTEM ND
WE SHOULD IMPLEMENT A SINGLE
PIECE SUCH AS THIS BILL.
WITHOUT CONSIDERING THE IMPACTS
OF THE MULTIPLE CARDS ON THE
SYSTEM PARTICULARLY WHEN IT
CONCERNS COLOR SLEEP
INVOLUNTARY TREATMENT LIKE THIS
BILL- DOES. AS THE COMEDIAN NOW
I WAS IS PROPERLY NO FOR THE
COMMITTEE SHOULD TAKE A LOOK
WHETHER IT IS INDEED PREMATURE
WE BELIEVE THAT IF THEY AND
AGAIN THAT THE- YEAH. EGGMAN
VERY ARE OF THE OF THE
AUDITOR'S PEOPLE THAT IT LOOKS
POLICE. AN AS LIKELY TO NOTED
IN THE TO COMMITTEE SCORE OF
THE- WE CIVIL RIGHTS ARE.
IMPLICATED AS THEY ARE IN THIS
BILL THAT'S WE BELIEVE THAT THE
BILL WOULD THREATEN THE
DELIVERY OF SERVICE USING THE
LEAST RESTRICTIVE ENVIRONMENT.
AND SHOULD BE FULLY THAT AND
CONSIDERED IN LIGHT OF THE
AUDITOR'S REPORT SO FOR THESE
REASONS WE SPECIFICALLY OPPOSE
THE BILL AND- OKAY THANK YOU.
WE ARE NOW- HEAR FROM-
OPPOSITION. BEGIN TO IDENTIFY
YOURSELF JUST BY NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION WILL
MOVE TO ANY WITNESSES HERE IN
THE CHAMBER ON THE GALLERY I
SEE NONE. ATTORNEY WITNESSES IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY WHO STEP TO
FIND OPPOSITION I SEE NONE.
THANK YOU KNOW MOVE ON TO
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY
VIA THE TELECONFERENCE ANSWER
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROPERTY INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF AB
NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX. YOU HAVE
FOR AN OPPOSITION. TO BILL ONE
NINE SEVEN SIX AND PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO IF YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU FOR NOT.
PLEASE BE AND YES. WELL GO TO
LINE ONE SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE ROBERT HARRIS ON THE
YEAH MESSI ARE YOU CALIFORNIA
IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL THANK.
THANK YOU THIS WITNESS. NINE
ONE ZERO EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING STACEY CEREMONIAL
WITH RAM COLD TO RACIAL AND
ETHNIC MENTAL HEALTH
DISPARITIES COALITION WE ARE
ALSO IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU
X. WITNESS. ONE ONE SIXTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON FUNDING VERY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL A COMMUNITY
BAKER HOPE AGENCY AND WE HAVE A
COUPLE. THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
LINE ONE FIFTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. A GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS SALLY IS AND THEN I'M WITH
THE CALIFORNIA ESPECIALLY. CAN
WE BRING THAT PERSON BACK ON
OUR. LINE ONE FIFTY ONE. PLEASE
ON YOUR PHONE. LOCAL TO ONE OF
ONE THIRTY ONE. LINE ONE THIRTY
THREE YEAR LINE OF OPEN. THANK
YOU GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE PHARMACY
CHAIN WITH THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES I KNOW
I'M AN IN BETWEEN OR WITHIN A
CO THE LET THE MANDATE.
PROVISION OF THE SHORT POINT
I'D LIKE TO MAKE IS THAT- WE'D
LIKE EVERYTHING IN THE BILL
EXCEPT FOR THE REQUIREMENT THE
COUNTIES- UP OUT OF THE T. IT'S
ALREADY A PUBLIC PROCESS WITH
COMMUNITY INPUT LIMITED
RESOURCES AND FOR COUNTIES
MANY. BUT VOTE TO OPT OUT IN
LIGHT OF A BUDGETARY RESOURCES
RIGHT NOW AND I THINK THAT
COULD AFFECT THE VIABILITY OF
THE COUNTY. OPTED OUT OF BACK
IN IN THE FUTURE. THANK YOU SO
MUCH THANK YOU. ARE THERE ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. MODERATOR VEGAN
PLEASE SUCH CHECK THE LINE FINE
THANK YOU. LINE ONE FIFTY ONE
HAS CUED UP AGAIN PLEASE GO
AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU THIS IS SALLY SAID NEWMAN.
I'M WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF MENTAL HEALTH.
CARE ROM ORGANIZATIONS AND WE
OPPOSED BILL. THANK YOU. ARE
THERE ANY A THERE ARE NO
ADDITIONAL LINES AND OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU MODERATOR OKAY-
HAVING HEARD FROM BOTH SIDES-
NOW OPEN TO QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
A CENTER RUBIO. THANK YOU
CHAIR- FIRST FIVE ONE I THINK A
ASSEMBLY MEMBER EGGMAN FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD- IN I TO
RESPECT THE CONCERNS OF A
COUNTIES AS IT PERTAINS TO
BEING I'M CONCERNED ABOUT THE
FINANCIAL IMPACT BUT I DO.
BELIEVE THAT THIS IS A THE
MIDDLE GROUND AND THEY DO HAVE
THE OPTION TO OPT OUT I WAS
BRIEFED ON THE AUDIT AND ONE
THING IS VERY CLEAR AND THAT IS
THAT THE SERVICES ARE
ABSOLUTELY NECESSARY SO I
BELIEVE THAT THIS IS A GOOD
MEASURE AND I WOULD LIKE TO BE
ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR WHEN
APPROPRIATE AND I DO SUPPORT
THIS BILL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
CENTER RUBIO CENTER MINING.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I TOO
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS I SUPPORT THE
BILL TODAY I APPRECIATE THE
CONCERNS RAISED BY OPPONENTS
WE'VE HEARD THESE ARGUMENTS IN
THE PAST AND I THINK. THE
CHALLENGE TO FIND SUFFICIENT
COMMUNITY RESOURCES TO PROVIDE.
FULL PARITY IN MENTAL HEALTH
TREATMENT IS AN ONGOING
CHALLENGE FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THAT SAID. THE
REMEDIES THAT MADE AVAILABLE BY
LARA IS LAW SHOULD A COUNTY
OFTEN UNDER THIS BILL. VITA
REMEDY THAT IS CRITICAL IN
CIRCUMSTANCES WHERE A MENTALLY
ILL PERSON IS NOT CAPABLE OF
SEEKING HELP VOLUNTARILY- IN
WHO MAY DO GREAT DAMAGE TO HIM
OR HERSELF OR TO OTHERS I ALSO
JUST WANTED TO TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY. TO THANK MR MRS
WILCOX FOR THEIR YEARS OF
ADVOCACY THE TRAGIC LOSS OF
THEIR DAUGHTER LARA. HAS
INSPIRED THERE- TIRELESS
ADVOCACY TO HELP OTHER FAMILIES
BOTH FAMILIES OF VICTIMS AND
ALSO FAMILIES OF THOSE WHO
DON'T HAVE ALTERNATIVES OR
REMEDIES DEALING WITH THE
MENTALLY. ILL RELATIVE- SO FOR
THOSE REASONS ALL BE SUPPORTING
THE BILL TODAY AND HOPE THAT IT
WILL FURTHER THE CONVERSATION
OF THE NEED TO. EXPAND SUPPORT
FOR ALL MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
IN OUR COMMUNITIES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY OTHER
MEMBERS WHO WISH TO SPEAK. OKAY
MICROPHONES. OKAY WITH THAT
THIS SUMMARY EGGMAN WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MEMBERS FOR YOUR TIME AND
ATTENTION TO THIS ISSUE- YOU
KNOW AT THE END EVERY
LEGISLATIVE YEAR WE DON'T KNOW
A FOR. WILL BE BACK AGAIN OR
NOT AND SO THIS IS MY CHANCE IN
CASE I DID NOT RETURN TO THE
CHAMBERS TO BE ABLE TO ACTUALLY
DO SOMETHING ON ON WHAT I
WORKED MY WHOLE LIFE ON AROUND
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES. AGAIN
THIS IS ONE PART OF A PACKAGE
AYE I UNDERSTAND WE NEED TO
IMPROVE MENTAL HEALTH ACROSS
THE SYSTEM I AM COMMITTED TO
DOING THAT AGAIN IN THIS BILL
WE HAD WE SAY THAT YOU YOU MAY
NOT IMPEMENTED AND TAKE FROM
CHILDREN SERVICES OR OTHER-
VOLUNTARY SERVICES. AT THE END
WE AS MY AS MY YOUNG MAYOR
WOULD SAY SOMETIMES WE HAVE TO
UPSET THE SET UP AND I THINK
THAT'S WHAT WE HAVE TO DO WITH
OUR MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM. AND I
THIS IS ONE MORE STEP TOWARDS
DOING IT AND AGAIN I WOULD
REMIND YOU REMEMBER THIS ROOM
WITH THE EXCEPTION OF THE CHAIR
EVERYBODY ELSE OR HAS THIS IN
THEIR COUNTIES AND IMAGINE WHAT
IT MIGHT LOOK LIKE IF YOU
DIDN'T HAVE THIS ONE EXTRA
TOOL. AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. OKAY THANK
YOU SO MUCH CENTER AND THEN
FASHION MAY BECOME A BEFORE YOU
MADE YOUR CLOTHES I AM A THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
AND BRING THIS BILL FORD- I
APPRECIATE YOUR WORK WITH THE
VARIOUS STAKEHOLDERS. I PRETTY
TAKING THE AMENDMENTWE WHY
JUST BY A LITTLE MORE TIME FOR
THE COUNTIES- THE ONLY REYES
BUDGETARY ISSUES IS WHAT THE
BUDGET CYCLE AS WELL AS GIVING
SOME TIME FOR. A DIFFERENT
STAKEHOLDERS WITHIN EACH COUNTY
TO BE ABLE TO HAVE THAT
DISCUSSION ABOUT WHETHER THE
COUNTY WILL STAY AND ARE WHICH
IS NOT THE- TIME. IS VERY MUCH
A IS THE MOTION FOR THIS BILL
OKAY IT'S BEEN MOVED BY SARAH
CENTER MINING- THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. SEC PLEASE CALL.
THE MY OF MEMBERS TO PLAY YOU
MAKE WHEN YOU. PAN HI CAN I
GONZALEZ I AND SALAS I GROW.
THE HI. GROW BY HER TARA HI THE
TOTAL AYE LEYVA HI LEYVA I.
MELENDEZ MITCHELL BY MITCHELL
MY MONEY IN MY MONEY I RUBIO HI.
RUBIO I EIGHT ZERO OKAY THAT
BILLS OUT EIGHT ZERO. RIGHT
LET'S MOVE ON TO OUR NEXT ITEM
IS ITEM NUMBER THREE EIGHTY
NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE BY SOME
MEMBER GARCIA I WOULD MAKE NOTE
I BELIEVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER THAT
YOU ARE ACTUALLY GONNA BE
PRESENTING TO BILLS- BOTH THIS
ITEM AND ALSO- WE WILL THEN
FOLLOW THAT WITH ITEM NUMBER
TEN WHICH IS AB TWENTY TWO
SEVENTY SIX BY SUMMER RACE
WHICH I BELIEVE YOU ARE
PRESENTING ON BEHALF OF SOME
THEIR RARE SELF. DETERMINED WE
ARE RIGHT NOW ON ITEM NUMBER
THREE AB NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE
BY SUMMER GARCIA WELCOME AND
PLEASE BEGIN YES THANK YOU I
BEGAN BY THANKING THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THEIR HARD WORK AND I
WILL BE ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS OUTLINED ON PAGE
FIVE. OF THE ANALYSIS. AB
NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE WILL
PROTECT PEOPLE'S HEALTH BY
REQUIRING THE DISCLOSURE OF ALL
INGREDIENTS. MR PRODUCTS
INCLUDING TAMPONS PADS. CUT
THIS FUNCHES AND MENSTRUAL
UNDERWEAR. IF YOU'RE NOT A
LUXURY AND PEOPLE SHOULD HAVE
THE KNOWLEDGE TO MAKE SAFER
CHOICES. I WOULD I THINK ALL
THE STAKEHOLDERS INCLUDING THE
SIERRA CLUB EITHER WOULD YOU WG
BREAST CANCER PREVENTION
PARTNERS AND WOMEN'S VOICES FOR
THE EARTH ALONG WITH OTHER
GROUPS TO AFTER MANY
STAKEHOLDER CONVERSATIONS HAVE
MOVED TO NEUTRAL ON THIS BILL.
AND SO WITH THOSE WE HAVE TATUM
ADLER WITH PNG GO TO PROVIDE
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
ENABLE. OKAY THANKS SO MUCH
CENTER GARCIA- WE WILL NOW MOVE
TO THE- WITNESSES AND SUPPORT
TO OUR TESTIFYING AND I HAVE
HERE- TATUM AKC LITTER FROM THE
PROCTER GAMBLE COMPANY- SO. YOU
CAN BRING. FITNESS ACTOR ONTO
THE LINE TO TESTIFY. AND YOU
HAVE A MAXIMUM OF FOUR MINUTES
YOU'RE NOT REQUIRED TO TAKE ALL
THE TIME IF YOU DON'T NEED IT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN THAT
ARE. NOT CLEAR WITH ARNOLD AND
PORTER ON BEHALF OF PROCTER AND
GAMBLE AND DEPORTED EIGHTY
NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE. RIGHT NO
ACTIVE TWENTY TWENTY AND I KNOW
YOU HAVE A LOT OF BILL BEFORE
YOU THIS AFTERNOON. THREE AFTER
YOUR BILL SHARED THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GOAL TO PROVIDE
MEANINGFUL AND ACCURATE
INGREDIENT FOR USERS OUT OF
CONTROL PRODUCT INTO
TRANSPARENCY FRAMEWORK FOR THE
NAVY NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE IS
CONSISTENT WITH PNG PONDERING
TRANSPARENCY EFFORT. DR MINIMAL
WORK EXTENSIVELY WITH YET
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OFFICE THE NGOS
IN OUR TREATED AS WE SHOULD
PARTNER THE CENTER FOR BABY AND
I TOLD AGING PRODUCT. BUT IT
ALSO GOT NEUTRAL ON THAT
MEASURE. FOR THESE REASONS INTO
THE PORT. IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
NINE AND WE APPRECIATE. YEAH
AND HER STAFF. ON THE ISSUE.
YEAH THANK VERY MUCH WILL NOW
MOVE TO WITNESSES- THE TWO
IDENTIFY THEMSELVES BY NAME-
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION ONLY
HERE IN THE GALLERY SCENE NONE
ARE THERE ANY IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY SEEING NONE LET'S MOVE TO
THE TELECONFERENCE LINE-
MODERATOR WE IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE- PROMPTS THE INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
OF AB. NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE. IF
YOU ARE IN SUPPORT FOR A BI
NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. ONE ZERO IF YOU
ARE IN SUPPORT. YOU HAVE TO AND
SUPPORT LINE ONE TWO SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU- DOCTOR CHAIRED
MEMBERS THIS IS MORE FOR GAS ON
BEHALF OF THE BOYS FOR CHOICE
ADVOCACY- WE STAND IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THE ASSEMBLY WOMAN AB
NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE THANK YOU
FOR WORK. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. NINE ONE THREE EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. DANIEL GUTIERREZ ON
BEHALF OF THE CONSUMER
FEDERATION OF CALIFORNIA WE
HAVE A SUPPORT AMENDED POSITION
ON THE BILL- FOR THE REASONS
STATED IN OUR LETTER. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES- PLEASE
CHECK PLAN AGAIN AND SUPPORT.
IF YOU ARE AND SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME ONE
ZERO. THERE ARE NO OTHER LINE
HAVE CUED UP THANK YOU SO MUCH
MODERATOR WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
OPPOSITION I UNDERSTAND WE HAVE
TWO WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION WHO
WILL BE TESTIFYING- NATALIE
BROUGH FROM THE DRESS
TRANSITION ALLIANCE AND EIGHTY
KYLE RETIRED HEALTH PROFESSOR
UC BERKELEY SO WE CAN BEGIN
WITH- MISS BROUGH. AND AGAIN
THERE'S A MAXIMUM OF FOUR
MINUTES FOR BOTH WITNESSES.
GOOD MORNING CAN YOU HEAR ME
BUT YES WE CAN PLEASE BEGIN.
THANK HERE MY NAME IS NATALIA
BROUGH AND I AM CALLING AND
OPPOSITION TO AB NINETEEN
EIGHTY NINE I AM THE PROUD
DAUGHTER OF A CANCER SURVIVOR
MOTHER TO A CHILD AND I'M WITH
A RARE DISEASE THAT MOTHER TO A
COURAGEOUS WOMAN BATTLING AGE
FOR YOU DURING CANCER AND
WARRIOR MY OWN FRIDAY AGAIN AND
I NEED TO BE THERE YOU MIGHT
SAY THAT THE WOMEN IN MY FAMILY
OF ONE THE BAD HEALTH LOTTERY
BUT THERE'S NO WAY THAT THESE
DISEASES ARE PURELY OUR FAMILY
FORTUNE TO BATTLE THERE'S NO
DOUBT THAT A GREAT DEAL. OF
WHAT WE FACE IS DUE TO THE
UNWARRANTED CHEMICAL TRACK
HAPPENS WITH- DUE TO THE
ONGOING A LONG STANDING REFUSAL
TO ELIMINATE. TOXIC CHEMICALS
AND TRY. BECAUSE I RECOGNIZE
THE TOPIC. IN NEXT. IN OUR
LIVES I'M GOING TO WITH
ADOPTION ALLIANCE AN
ORGANIZATION THAT FOR DECADES
HAS WORKED. IN THE PJ MOVEMENT
AMONG OTHER THINGS. ACT
COMMUNITIES AND FAMILIES LIKE
BROWN FROM THE CORRECT THAT
QUITE FRIGHTENING AFFECT THE
TOXIC CHEMICALS. WHILE I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK TODAY TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL
INTRODUCED BY A FAMILY MEMBER
BIRTH YEAH I AM ALSO ANGERED
AND FRUSTRATED THAT WE ACTUALLY
EVEN HAVE TO HAVE THESE
CONVERSATIONS REGARDING WHETHER
OR NOT WE SHOULD BE ALLOWING
TOXIC CHEMICALS TO BE INCLUDED
IN SOME OF THE MOST. INTIMATE
PRODUCT WE NEED TO USE THE
WOMEN. I AM FAIRLY CONCERNED
THAT THIS BILL WOULD PUSHED
FORWARD DURING THAT TIME WHICH
PREVENT PREVENTED MEANINGFUL
ENGAGEMENT DJ COMMUNITIES. WITH
COLD AND THAT STRUGGLE TO END
FOR POLICE BRUTALITY AND RACIAL
INJUSTICE AGAINST BLACK AND
BROWN COMMUNITY. ORGANIZATIONS
LIKE GTA HAVE HAVEN'T HAD THE
FACT CAPACITY OR RESOURCES
NEEDED TO ENSURE BUILT LIKE THE
PLAN REFLECT THE BEST INTERESTS
AND NEEDS AT THE AGE A
COMMUNITY THAT WE KNOW CARE
ABOUT THIS ISSUE. AND WE KNOW
WE CARE ABOUT THIS ISSUE
BECAUSE WE'RE THE MOST IMPACT
OUR COMMUNITY ARE READY FACTOR
PRIMITIVE DISPROPORTIONATE
IMPACT. ON THE LACK OF
REGULATION I'M PARK THE
CHEMICALS SO WE KNOW FIRST HAND
HOW IMPORTANT IT IS TO ENGAGE
IN YET ANOTHER PROPOSAL THAT
WILL DIRECT BURGER VIOLATE OUR
RIGHT AT THIS TIME. AND THIS
TIME AT THE PHYSICALLY
TARGETING OUR DAUGHTERS MOTHERS
AND GRANDMOTHERS. THE CURRENT
BILL IS WEAKER THAN THE
LEGISLATION THAT WITH FINANCIAL
LAW LAST YEAR IN NEW YORK IT'S
POPULAR RIGHT ITS APPROACH
BETTER A LOT TO REQUIRE FULL
DISCLOSURE. OF INGREDIENTS. AND
OUR PRODUCTS. AS PART OF THE
LEGISLATIVE. TO BERMAN OBJECT.
IN AB NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE
SHORT. IT HAS BEEN PUSHED HER
TO QUIT AND I. YOU AND THE CA.
FIND TODAY I YOU TO VOTE NOW AB.
EIGHTY NINE. THANKS VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY NOW IT SAYS
HERE FROM THIS KYLE. HELLO CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES AGAIN PLEASE
BEGIN. OKAY GREAT- I'M JUST
LETTING YOU KNOW THAT I AM
ACTUALLY READING THIS TESTIMONY
FOR- DOCTOR COYOTE AND SHE WAS
NO LONGER ABLE TO OKAY. WE HEAR
HERSELF AND HER TO READ IT
BECAUSE OF THE DELAY OKAY FIRST
OF ALL PLEASE INTRODUCE
YOURSELF I KNOW YOU'RE SPEAKING
BEHALF OF MISS KYLE AND THEN
YOU ACTUALLY ONLY HAVE A MINUTE
AND A HALF LEFT SO. JUST KEEP
THAT IN MIND. TO BEGIN
INTRODUCE YOURSELF OKAY AND SO
WE KNOW WHO'S SPEAKING AND I
KNOW YOU SPEAKING BEHALF OF
MISS KYLE. AND THEN BEGIN THANK
YOU. GREAT OKAY MY NAME IS
KATHERINE I'M CONTENT I AM AND-
AT. POLICY DIRECTOR FOR CENTER
FOR ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH.
BEYOND THE HAPPENED AB KYLE
GOOD MORNING DOCTOR PAN AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
AMY KYLE AND I MY HEALTH PUBLIC
HEALTH SCIENTISTS AND RECENTLY
RETIRED MEMBER OF THE FACULTY
OF THE SCHOOL OF PUBLIC HEALTH
HEALTH AT UC BERKELEY WITH
EXPERTISE AND CHEMICALS POLICY.
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
APPEAR AND FOR YOUR WORK ON
BEHALF OF THE PEOPLE OF THE
STATE. I TRULY HONOR THE EFFORT
THAT IT TAKES TO MAKE PROGRESS
DURING THIS TIME. I AM SPEAKING
ABOUT THE CONFIDENTIAL BUSINESS
INFORMATION PROVISIONS OF AB IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE. AND WE'RE
RECOMMENDING FURTHER
DEVELOPMENT. NATURAL PRODUCTS
ARE ESSENTIAL BUT CAN EXPOSE
WOMEN TO HARMFUL CHEMICALS. I
THANK YOU AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GARCIA FOR YOUR ATTENTION TO
THIS. DISCLOSURE AND AN
IMPORTANT PLACE TO START. WE
KNOW THAT TOXIC CHEMICALS CAN
BE IN MONSTER PRODUCT LEADING
TO EXPOSURE. WOMEN AND PUBLIC
HELP. NEED TO KNOW WHAT
CHEMICALS ARE YOU. ADDRESSING
CONFIDENTIAL BUSINESS
INFORMATION REQUIRED BALANCE
BETWEEN THE INTERESTS OF
CORPORATIONS AND PROFITING FROM
PRODUCT. AND INTERESTS OF THE
PUBLIC IN PROTECTING THOSE WHO
USE THEM. THE APPROACH HERE
SHOULD BE FURTHER DEVELOPED TO
ADDRESS THREE KEY ISSUES. THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WOULD RELY
ONE THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
WOULD RELY ON DECISION BY U.
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION AGENCY
ABOUT WHAT DATA CAN BE BUT HOW.
HOWEVER THE US EPA HAS TAKEN
APART ENVIRONMENTAL AND PUBLIC
HEALTH PROTECTIONS FOR TOPICS
AND THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA HAS
CHALLENGED MANY OF THOSE
ACTIONS. WHY WOULD THE
LEGISLATURE SEEKING DECISION TO
US EPA. HERE I'M ADDRESS LEARN
ABOUT VITAMINS LET THIS IS
PREFERRED BY THE CHEMICAL
INDUSTRY BUT IT SCIENTIFICALLY
BOGUS OKAY I AM THE NEXT
THEY'RE NOT WHAT CHANGES WILL
USE IN OUR TECH EIGHT BEHIND
YOU WE ARE YOU ARE OUT OF TME.
IF YOU COULD PLEASE WRAP UP.
SHARE AT THE PROPOSAL WELL THE
BORDERLINE TO A GREAT EXTENT ON
THE FEDERAL TALK AT. A TOPIC
THAT YOU CONTROL ACT EVEN THE
MANAGER PRODUCT WOULD APPEAR TO
BE EXCLUDED CATEGORY OF DRUGS.
MEDICAL DEVICES AND COSMETICS I
RESPECTFULLY RECOMMEND THAT
PROVISIONS FOR CONFIDENTIAL
BUSINESS INFORMATION BE FURTHER
DEVELOPED IN CONSULTATION WITH
GROUPS THAT REPRESENT HI NEAT
IMPACTED COMMUNITIES THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME TODAY. THANK YOU
SO MUCH TESTIMONY OKAY. WE WILL
NOW HEAR FROM OPPOSITION
WITNESSES. HERE IN THE GALLERY
SEEING NONE AND ROOM TWENTY
FORTY SAYING NINE. NOW ON A
TELEPHONIC WINE MODERATORS YOU-
PLEASE- AS FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE
TESTIFYING IN OPPOSITION. TO
EIGHTY NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE AND
AGAIN IT'S NAME ORGANIZATION
AND POSITION. IF YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION OF AB. ONE NINE
EIGHT NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO ONE ZERO IF YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
AND YOU DO HAVE ONE IN
OPPOSITION. PLEASE BE IN. LINE
ONE ANYBODY. NINE ONE FIVE NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. I AM CALLING FOR OKAY
GRAVEL EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE JUST TRANSITION ALLIANCE
SEVERAL CORBIN MARK DEPUTY
DIRECTOR WE ACT FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE. CAPPY
CURTIS CO DIRECTOR JEFF GREEN
PARTNERSHIP KATIE HAPPENING
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF WINE FOR
NURSES FOR HEALTHY ENVIRONMENT
CATHERINE I CONTACT WILL POLICY
DIRECTOR CENTER FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH. HAVE BEEN
DENIED WAY YEAH EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR FOR PHYSICIANS FOR
SOCIAL RESPONSIBILITY LOS
ANGELES. BODIES WILDING DEPUTY
DIRECTOR CLEAN AND HEALTHY NEW
YORK AND CAROL WESTINGHOUSE
PRESIDENT INFORMED GREEN
SOLUTION. WE OPPOSE WITHOUT.
THANK YOU AT ANY OF WITNESSES
ON THE. LINE IN OPPOSITION. NO
ADDITIONAL LINE SIR OKAY SEEING
NONE ARE THERE QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
OKAY SEEING NONE OF CENTER GUY
A SIMILAR GARCIA MY THANK YOU
FOR YOUR HARD WORK ON THIS BILL
I KNOW THIS IS A PRODUCT OF
MANY YEARS OF WORK WITH MANY
STAKEHOLDERS. I KNOW THAT WELL
CERTAINLY THERE MAY BE SOME
PEOPLE WHO MAY HAVE CONCERNS
ABOUT DIFFERENT PARTS- YOU KNOW
WE CAN'T LET THE PERFECT BE THE
ENEMY OF THE GOOD AND I THINK
IT IMPRVES UP TRANSPARENCY AND
DANCES- SOME VERY IMPORTANT-
IDEAS FOR TOO AGAIN A PROTECT.
WOMEN SO WITH THAT WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE. UP THANK YOU FOR
THOSE COMMENTS SO LET THAT SON
OF MY CLOSING I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR NAVAL. OKAY THANK YOU
IS THERE A MOTION. OKAY A YEAR
HERE I HAVE A MOTION FROM.
SENATOR MITCHELL AND THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS- SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. PAN HI
CAN I GONZALEZ I GONZALEZ I
GREW. TARO HI FOR TOTAL AYE
LEYVA HI LEYVA AYE MELENDEZ
MITCHELL HI MITCHELL AYE
MONNING HI MONEY AND I RUBIO HI
RUBIO HI. OKAY THAT BILLS OUT
SEVEN ZERO HEY THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT WE'RE GONNA NOW MOVE ON
TO ITEM NUMBER TEN EIGHTY TWO
TWO SEVEN SIX BY SOME MEMBER
RADIUS AND WILL BE PRESENTED BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA AGAIN
BEGAN PLEASE BEGIN YES THANK
YOU FOR EVERY ARE SEVERAL
STUDIES HAVE DEMONSTRATED
CHILDHOOD LEAD EXPOSURE HAS
BEEN ASSOCIATED WITH TOXIC
EFFECTS ON THE IMMUNE SYSTEM.
WHICH CAN LEAD TO HIGHER
FRACTURE RATES OF COVER
NINETEEN WE HAVE MADE STRIDES
OVER THE YEARS TO ENSURE
CHILDREN RECEIVE TESTING FOR
LEAD POISONING THROUGH THE
CHILDHOOD LEAD POISONING
PREVENTION PROGRAM. BUT LAST
YEAR'S AUDIT LIVES KNOW THAT WE
HAVE WORK TO DO. AB TWENTY TWO
SEVENTY SIX WHAT AT SEVEN MORE
LEAD EXPOSURE RISK FACTORS THAT
WOULD HAVE CRIED TESTING AND
PLACE ALL EIGHT AND THE HEALTH
AND SAFETY CODE. AB TWENTY TWO
SEVENTY SIX ALSO REQUIRES THE
CD P. H. TO REVISE THE FUNDING
FORMULA TO ENSURE THE EQUITABLE
ALLOCATION OF FUNDS. BASED ON
THE MOST RECENT DATA REGARDING
ELEVATED LEAD LEVELS IN
CHILDREN. CALIFORNIA RANKED
THIRTY FIRST AMONG STATE IN THE
NATION FOR PROVIDING LET TEST
AND TWO YEAR OL CHILDREN.
OVERALL LESS THAN 2027% OF
ELIGIBLE CHILDREN RECEIVE ALL
REQUIRED THROUGH MEANS BETWEEN
TWO THOUSAND NINE AND EIGHTEEN.
AB TWENTY TWO SEVENTY SIX WILL
ENSURE HAT CHILDREN ENROLLED
IN MEDICAL REVIEW THE REQUIRED
LEVEL TESTING. THIS BILL ALL
ENSURE THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES. MEET AT
STATE AND FEDERAL MANDATES FOR
BLOOD AND THAT TESTING- THIS
BILL IS A COMPILATION OF THREE
ASSEMBLY BILL THAT WERE
INTRODUCED. TO IMPROVE THE WORK
THAT THE DEPARTMENT HAS ALREADY
BEEN DOING AND I WANT TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE STAFF. FOR TAKING
THE EFFORT TO COMBINE ALL THESE
TO BE BUILT INTO ONE UNITED-
MEASURE PERSPECTIVE THE ASPIRIN
ABLE. OKAY THANKS VERY MUCH
SUNLAND. ZERO THE TO MOVE ON TO
WITNESSES AND SUPPORT- SO WHAT
I HAVE HERE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL- DAPHNE
MACKLIN FROM THE COALITION OF
CALIFORNIA WILL FOR RIGHTS
ORGANIZATIONS AND LINDA NO WAY
FROM THE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY. SO MODERATOR- YOU
COULD GET THEM ON THE LINE AND
I DON'T KNOW IF- MISMATCH PLAN
IS- ON THE LINE I UNDERSTAND
SHE MAY NOT BE. OKAY JUST
CHECK. AND IF NOT THEN WE'LL
MOVE ON TO LONDON NóI. PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MONDAY NIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON WENT
AWAY WITH WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY HOW COUPONS OR THAT
AB TWENTY TWO SEVENTY SIX WHICH
IMPLEMENTED THE RECENT STATE
AUDITOR'S REPORT THAT FOUND THE
STATE IT FAILING TO TEST FOR
CHILDREN FOR LIKELY NEED TO
FIGHT EXISTING STATE AND
FEDERAL MANDATES THAT REQUIRES
ALL MEDI CAL OTHER DETECTED IT
EACH ONE SHE- IT IS IMPORTANT
THAT CHILDREN PARTICULARLY
CHILDREN. HAVE ACCESS TO BLOOD
LEAD CAT AND THERE'S NO STATE
LEVEL OF BLACK AND LIKELY HAD
LIKE LONG IRREVERSIBLE HARM
CLOTHING NINETEEN HIGHLIGHTED
THE DISPARITIES IN OUR HEALTH
CARE SYSTEM THE BILL REQUIRES
ADDITIONAL ATTENTION ON HIRING
THAT CODE IN PROXIMITY TO LET
PRETTY SILLY LOCATIONS WHERE
PREDOMINANTLY FAMILY OF COLOR
BLACK. IN ADDITION IF THE
REQUIRED DATA CAL PLANNED BY A
PROVIDER A FAMILY PLAN WHICH
HAD A LIQUID OF ACQUIRED LET
LET CASH IN REQUIRED PUBLIC
REPORTING ON THE NUMBER OF MEDI
CAL CHILDREN WHO HAVE AND HAVE
NOT REPEAT THAT TEST WE
APPRECIATE THE COMMISSION STAFF
WORK ON THIS BILL AND URGE YOUR
AYE VOTE ON THE FLY PARTY. THE
BILL THAT PASSED. ASSEMBLY
UNANIMOUSLY THANK YOU. OKAY
THANK YOU AND I UNDER THIS
MACKLIN IS NOW. YOU CAN PLEASE
BRING HER ON THE LINE. BACK
WHEN PLEASE CALL. MAC ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. OKAY SHE MAY SHE WON
MONEY ON THE PUBLIC COMMENT
LINES IF YOU CAN PLEASE CHECK
THE PUBLIC COMMENT MIND SEE IF
YOU CAN FIND HER. YES SIR. MS
MACKLIN IF YOU'RE ON THE PUBLIC
LINE PLEASE GO AHEAD AND PRESS
ONE IS ZERO AT THIS TIME. THIS
MACKLIN IF YOU ARE ON THE LINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD AND PRESS STAR
ZERO. START SHE IS NOT SHOWING
UP. OKAY WELL- PERHAPS THE
WE'LL SEE IF SHE SHOWS UP WHEN
WE GET THROUGH THE TELEFONICA
WILL COME AND STAND ALRIGHT
THEN WITH THAT SELECT BEFORE WE
MOVE ON. A SUMMER GARCIA I JUST
WANNA CONFIRM BUT IT TO YOU ON
BEHALF OF SUMMER RATES ARE
TAKING THE AMENDMENTS- THAT THE
COMMITTEES OFFERED. YES THANK
YOU WE WILL- LET ME TAKE THE
AMENDMENTS AND APPRECIATE THE
STUFF WORK ON THIS BILL. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OKAY SO LET'S
MOVE ON TO WITNESSES.
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT WITH NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION FIRST
UP IN THE GALLERY I DO NOT SEE
ANY WITNESS UP IN GALLERY
PULLED AND MOVE ON TO ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. NOT SEE ANY THERE
LET'S MOVE ON TO THE TELEPHONE
LINES MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE OPEN THE LINES IN CALLED
THE SUPPORT WITNESSES- WE WILL.
CONTINUE IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT
FOR BELL AB TWO TWO SEVEN SIX.
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. WE'LL GO
TO THE LINE OF ONE SIX TO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THE FUTURE
NUMBERS ONE THAT YOU KNOW WHAT
WITH THE CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC
HEALTH NETWORK IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. NINE
ONE SIX THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON REBEKAH GONZALEZ
pWORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
ONE ONE FIVE TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THE MORNING CALL WITH
FEAR CLUB CALIFORNIA AND FOR
THE BILL. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. NINE ONE SIX ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. NINE ONE SIX. NINE ONE
SIX ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO. YES PLEASE
INTRODUCE REWRITE. LINE ONE SIX
ONE PLEASE INTRODUCE YOURSELF.
MY GOD WHAT ARE THEY DOING ON.
NINE ONE SIX ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. OKAY IS THERE ARE THERE
THAT THEIR LINE IN OUR NEXT
WITNESS IN ANY OTHER WITNESSES.
SURE THERE ARE NO ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES AT THIS TIME. OKAY
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT OF HAVING
HEARD FROM THE- WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT LET'S MOVE ON TO THE
OPPOSITION- WE DO NOT HAVE ANY
LEAD OPPOSITION IDENTIFIED- SO
THE FIRST OF ALL WE'LL START
WITH WITNESSES IN THE CHAMBER
AND THEY'RE SAYING NONE IN
OPPOSITION IN THE CHAMBER WILL
MOVE TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
SAYING NONE IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY WILL MOVE ON TO THE
TELEPHONIC LINES- MODERATOR
PLEASE- INVITE WITNESSES WHO
WISH TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
TO- EIGHTY TWENTY TO SEVENTY
SIX- TO PLEASE TESTIFIED. IF
YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION TO AB TWO
TWO SEVEN SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. ONE ZERO IF YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION. NO ONE HAD CUED UP
OKAY. WITH THAT THERE'S NO ONE
AND DESPITE OPPOSITION ARE
THERE ANY COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS. YES
CENTER RUBIO. SURE MY FRIEND ON
THANK YOU THANK YOU CHAIR FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK AT
ONCE AGAIN THANK YOU TO THE
JOINT AUTHORS- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RAY IS WHICH I ALSO BELIEVE IN
INCLUDE SOME ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CRISTINA GARCIA AND MANY OTHERS
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD AT
WHAT I FOUND SHOCKING ON'T WAS
WITH THE STATE AUDITOR'S REPORT
RELEASED IN JANUARY TWENTY
TWENTY FOUND THAT MORE THAN ONE
POINT FOUR ONE AND TWO YEAR OLD
CHILDREN DID NOT RECEIVE STATE
REQUIRED LET LET SCREENING
TESTS WHICH IS REALLY. REALLY
DOES BOB UNFORTUNATE BECAUSE
THERE'S A COMPANY AND MY
DISTRICT THAT IN MAY OF TWENTY
TWENTY JUST PAID SIX HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN PENALTIES
FOR AIR POLLUTION VIOLATIONS
WHICH INCLUDED THE MISSIONS OF
LEAD AND THIS IS SUCH AN
IMPORTANT MEASURE TO GET AHEAD
OF US WHAT OUR CHILDREN ARE
GOING TO FACE STILL I WOULD
LOVE TO BE ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR
AS WELL AND I THINK THAT IT'S
AN IMPORTANT POINT MEASURE AND
I DID NOT URGE EVERYONE ELSE TO
SUPPORT IT AS WELL. THANK YOU.
RIGHT THANK YOU ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. THE
RIVER THE DO WHICH ELECT SECOND
THIS BILL. YES OKAY ALL RIGHT.
OKAY SEEN OTHER AT THAT
SOMEBODY NUMBER GARCIA FOR
SOMEONE THANK YOU AND YOUR
FELLOW AUTHORS AND CERTAINLY-
SOME A RACE IS THE AUTHOR OF
THIS BILL OF FOR YOUR WORK I
KNOW WE HAVE A COMBINED THE
THREE BILLS TOGETHER INTO ONE
AND- AGAIN APPRECIATE- I'M
PORTANT THIS IS WHICH IS LIKE
CLOSE TO THE RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR NAY VOTE. OKAY THANK YOU.
RIGHT SO. AND THIS IS A STE AB
TWENTY TWO SEVENTY SIX IT'S
BEEN MOVED BY CENTER RUBIO THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS AT SECTOR PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. PAN I CAN I
GONZALEZ I AND SALAS I GROW I
GROW BY TADA. LEYVA LEYVA AYE
MELINDA'S MITCHELL HI MITCHELL
AYE MONNING NINE MONNING AYE
RUBIO HI. FIFTY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT NUMBER SURE HE'S HER
TADA I HER TITLE BY. MELINDA'S.
OKAY THAT BILLS OUT EIGHT ZERO
THANKS FOR MUCH ALL RIGHT OUR
NEXT ITEM IS ITEM NUMBER FOUR.
AB TWENTY THIRTY SEVEN BY
SEVERAL WEEKS WILL BE PRESENTED
BY CENTER LEAVE IF YOU WISH TO
JUST DO IT FROM YOUR DESK- AND
THAT THE GREAT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIR AND LET ME FIRST BEGIN BY
THINKING YOU AND THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR YOUR WORK ON THIS
BILL FOR ASSEMBLYMEMBER WICKS
IT IS MUCH APPRECIATED.
CURRENTLY CALIFORNIA HOSPITALS
PLANNING ON CLOSING OR
DOWNGRADING SERVICES. ARE ONLY
REQUIRED REQUIRED TO GIVE A
NINETY DAY NOTICE. PRIOR TO
CLOSING TO THE SURROUNDING
PUBLIC. THREE MONTHS IS SIMPLY
NOT ENOUGH TIME FOR COMMUNITIES
TO VOICE THEIR CONCERNS TO THE
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS FIND
ALTERNATIVE LOCATIONS FOR
CRITICAL CARE. AND MAKE PLANS
TO ACCOMMODATE THEIR HEALTHCARE
NEEDS. WITH THE CURRENT STATE
OF OUR PUBLIC HEALTH COMBINED
WITH THE CONTINUED CRISIS OF
COVERT NINETEEN. COMMUNITY
SHOULD HAVE A RIGHT TO HAVE
MORE TIME TO ADVOCATE FOR
THEMSELVES AND THEIR FAMILIES
TO ACCESS HEALTH CARE. THE LOSS
OF HEALTH CARE AXIS OF THE
CLOSURE OF A HOSPITAL POSE A
SIGNIFICANT HEALTH RISKS FOR
LOW INCOME INDIVIDUALS OF THE
ELDERLY AND FAMILIES IN THE
COMMUNITY. WITH OR WITHOUT A
GLOBAL PLANT PANDEMIC. AFFECTED
COMMUNITY SHOULD BE ABLE TO
VOICE OUR CONCERNS ADVOCATE FOR
THEMSELVES AND THE LOCAL
ELECTED. AND BEGIN TO SEARCH
FOR ALTERNATIVE CARE. AS WELL
AS HOSPITAL STAFF AND PERSONNEL
SHOULD HAVE TIME TO FIND
ALTERNATIVE EMPLOYMENT. THE
CURRENT LAW OF NINETY DAYS
NOTIFICATION IS NOT NEARLY
ENOUGH TIME FOR ANY OF THESE
OPTIONS TO HAPPEN. AB TWENTY
THIRTY SEVEN EXTENSIVE PUBLIC
NOTIFICATION PERIODS FOR
HOSPITALS AND HEALTH FACILITIES
THAT PLAN TO DOWNGRADE
SERVICES. CHANGER SERVICES OR
CLOSE A FACILITY TO ONE HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY DAYS OR SIX MONTHS.
COMMUNITIES THE MORE NOTICE AND
TIME WHEN HOSPITALS CLOSE AS
THEY NEED ACCESS TO ESSENTIAL
CARE. AB TWENTY THIRTY SEVEN
GIVES COMMUNITIES AS PRECIOUS
TIME TO ABSOLUTE THEIR INFORMED
AND EMPOWERED DURING A TIME OF
TRANSITION. AND CHANGING ACCESS
TO HEALTH CARE RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU SO
MUCH CENTER LEYVA. THAT WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO WITNESSES
AND SUPPORT- SO WE HAVE A
TAILOR JACKSON FOR THE
CALIFORNIA NURSES ASSOCIATION
AND SERRA FLOCKS IN THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION AS
THE TWO WITNESSES TESTIFYING
SUPPORT MODERATOR KEY PLEASE
BRING THEM ON THE LINE.
STARTING WITH TAYLOR JACKSON.
JEFF HELLO MUTED. HELLO MISTER
TURN MEMBERS KILLER JACKSON
WITH A CALIFORNIA NURSES
ASSOCIATION WE ARE THE
FUNCTIONS OF THE BILL I NEED TO
KNOW THE BILL SECOND WITHIN
THEIR FLOCK WITH THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION WAS UNABLE TO
GET ON THE LINE DUE TO THE
DELAYED START TIME BUT SHE
ASKED ME TO CONVEY THE LABOR
CREDITS STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY THIRTY SEVEN I'D LIKE TO
THINK SENATOR LEYVA FOR HER
WILLINGNESS TO PRESENT THE BILL
ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WAY. I ALSO LIKE THE CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE STAFFER PRAYER
CLOSING THIS BILL DURING WATER
OBVIOUSLY UNIQUE TIME AB TWENTY
THIRTY SEVEN ASSEMBLY ASKING
FOR ADEQUATE NOTICE WHEN A
HOSPITAL BED TO CLOSE IT IS
SHOCKING BUT LARGE FOR PROFIT
COMPANIES CONTINUE TO CLOSE
SERVICES EVEN DURING A PANDEMIC
WHEN EVERYONE ELSE IS WORKING
TO PRESERVE A CUTE PAIR IF YOU
CARE BEDS WHEN AT ALL POSSIBLE
IN MAY OF THIS YEAR THREE
LEGISLATORS FROM SAN JOSE SANTA
LETTER TO HCA HEALTHCARE.
URGING THEM TO NOT CLOSE WOMEN
SERVICES WHICH INCLUDES LABOR
AND DELIVERY AND THE NEONATAL
INTENSIVE CARE NICK YOU AT
REGIONAL MEDICAL CENTER IN EAST
SAN JOSE THE NEAREST NICK YOU
FOR THE POPULATION OF ON THE
OTHER SIDE OF SANTA CLARA
COUNTY WE'LL PUT LOW INCOME
DELIVERING MOTHERS IN TRAFFIC
FOR UP TO AN HOUR TO RECEIVE
CARE THIS PROPOSED CLOSURE OF
VITAL SERVICES AND A LOWER
SOCIO ECONOMIC NEIGHBORHOOD. IS
THAT OR IN AT. ANYTIME TAKE
YOUR- IN DURING A HEALTH CRISIS
AND ABANDONED. COMMUNITIES NEED
IN APPROPRIATE AMOUNT OF TO.
FOR THE LAW. OF THEM ARE TO BE
IN LIKE THE SERVICE. WE MUST
INTO DURING THESE MOM. THE
HEALTHCARE DELIVERY TO IT OPEN
AND- OUR DOCTORS NURSES AND
CARE WORK. CAN CONTAIN SAVING.
A SUBSTANTIALLY SIMILAR
RECEIVED YOUR SUPPORT OUT OF
THIS COMMITTEE LAST YEAR AND
WAS SUBSEQUENTLY VETOED. I DO
WANT TO UPDATE YOU THAT WE HAVE
BEEN VERY PRODUCTIVE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE SO FAR AND
THERE'S A LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK ON THE FINAL
PUBLIC HEALTH POLICY. ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA NURSES
ASSOCIATION AND THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION I ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE ON AB TWENTY THIRTY
SEVEN. RIGHT THANKS VERY MUCH
AND AS YOU INDICATED I
UNDERSTAND THAT- BOXES NOT. ON
THE LINE RIGHT NOW SO WE'LL GO
AHEAD AND MOVE TO OTHER
WITNESSES AND- SUPPORT. IN THE
GALLERY. NINE LET'S MOVE TO THE
TELEPHONE LINES- MODERATOR FEE
PLEASE. ASK OPEN THE LINES AND
ASK THE WITNESSES AND SUPPORT
TO BE A PREPARE TESTIMONY. IF
YOU ARE IN SUPPORT FOR THIS
BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME ONE ZERO. AND CARE
YOU HAVE ONE PERSON AND SUPPORT
LOCAL TO LINE ONE SIXTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. JERRY MEMBERS
AT NIGHT WAS A ON BEHALF OF THE
ESTATE YOU CALIFORNIA SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES. NOT AT THIS TIME SIR
RIGHT LET'S MOVED OUT TO THE
OPPOSITION AND TESTIFYING IN
OPPOSITION IS CAPTAIN SCOTT FOR
THE CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION SO YOU CAN PLEASE
BRING HER ON THE LINE. GOOD
AFTERNOON THAT THE PASSWORD GOT
THE CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION. I CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC HAVE BEEN WORKING HARD
TO MEET THE THIRD. I THINK YOU
COULD CARE FOR THE PATIENT.
CAN'T AND EVERYONE ELSE NEEDING
AMER BE MEDICAL DURING PUBLIC
HEALTH. PRIOR TO THE CO LEADERS
THEY WIDE. ONE IN THREE
HOSPITAL AND TELL ARE SHOWING
SIGNS OF DISTRESS. SPONSORED
CREDIT AND WE CAN BE USE THE
YEAR APPLE NOT FREAKING. MARKET
EVERYTHING BY THE OLYMPIC BILL
AND A LOT FOR CALIFORNIA. HELLO
TWENTY THIRTY SEVEN AND ONE AB
TWENTY THIRTY SEVEN
REQUIREMENTS OF A HUNDRED
MEETING NOTICE FOR CLOSER WOULD
LIKELY NOT MY PREMATURE LOSS OF
HIGHLY SKILLED HEALTHCARE
WORKERS LIMITING ACCESS TO CARE
FOR PATIENTS IN THE KEY. THANK
YOU VERY PROJECT THE CLOSER.
HOSPITAL MAY NEED TO CLOSER
RELOCATED SERVICE ABOUT THE
NEEDS OF THE COMMUNITY FOR THE
HOPE OF THE HOSPITAL THE TOP
LOOKING. FOR WHAT'S HOT
CLOSURES THE TOP OF THE TO KEEP
THE AND- TRAINING NEEDED. AJ
ALSO WORK THE BILL IN.
EXCEPTION FOR CASES THE CURRENT
THE TECHNICIAN ECONOMIC CIRCLE.
UNCLE A LOT FOR QUALITY CONCERN
CLOSED EARLY CLOSE YOUR LOCAL
REDUCTIONS AND- PRETTY AGREED
TO TAKE A REMAIN FOR CREDIT FOR
THE CURRENT SELLING. THANK YOU
YOUR CARE THANKS VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY AND SO WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY
IN OPPOSITION. FIRST THE- THERE
ARE WITNESSES IN GALLERY LET'S
MOVE TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY THERE
ARE NO WITNESSES IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY SO LET'S MOVE TO
TELEPHONIC LINE MODERATOR IF
YOU CAN PLEASE OPEN THE LINES
IN CALL FOR WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. TO EIGHTY TWENTY
THIRTY SEVEN- PLEASE HAVE THEM
BEGIN. YES SIR IF YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION TO BILL A. B. TWO
ZERO THREE SEVEN PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME ONE ZERO.
AND HERE YOU DO HAVE TO IN
OPPOSITION. TO THE TO BEGIN ONE
ONE THREE NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON STRUCTURE MEMBERS
CORNY DELGADO ON BEHALF OF THE
DISTRICT HOSPITAL LEADERSHIP
FORMALLY HAVE OPPOSED THE LESS
AMENDED MICROLINER COMMENTS TO
THAT THE G. HA THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS. NINE ONE SIX
EIGHT. PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. ONE SIX EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YOU CAN ACTUALLY CHAIR
MEMBERS MAKING LOW FOR ON
BEHALF OF THE UNITED HOPEFULLY.
HOW COMMON WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CONSTITUTION. THANK YOU ARE
THERE ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION. NO SIR NOT ISSUE
NOW WITNESSES ALL RIGHT WITH
THAT- QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS. OKAY
SAYING NONE HIGH GENERALLY
LIGHT SO I THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR PRESENTATION- THIS IS-
ILL FOR SIMILAR BILL IN THE
PAST I THINK MANY OF US
RECOGNIZE THAT WELL CERTAINLY-
EVER HOSPITALS AND EIGHTY IN
DISTRESS. RATE COVERED WE ALSO
NEED TO GIVE THE OPPORTUNITY
FOR THE COMMUNITY TO BE
INVOLVED IN A TIMELY MANNER SO
THAT THE COMMITTEE CAN SEE WHAT
RESOURCES THEY CAN RALLY AS
WELL AS OF COURSE WORKING WITH
THE HOSPITAL ENSURE THAT
THERE'S APPROPRIATE PLANS- FOR
MEETING SERVICES SO WITH THAT
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU IS THERE A
MOTION. OKAY IT'S BEEN MOVED
BY. A CENTER MITCHELL SO THE
MOTION IS- DO PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS BEEN MOVED BY
SIR MITCHELL ASPECTTRUE PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. PAN HI CAN I AND-
AYE GONZALEZ I GROW NO. PROOF
NO HER CADA. LEYVA HI LEYVA AYE
MELENDEZ MITCHELL HI MITCHELL
AYE MONNING NAY MONEY IN FIVE.
AYE RUBIO AYE. OKAY THE BILL IS
OUT SIX ONE THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT OUR NEXT ITEM IS ITEM
NUMBER FIVE AB TWENTY SEVENTY
SEVEN BY SUMMER TING I SEE HIM
PODIUM WELL COME AND PLEASE
BEGIN THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AB
TWENTY SEVENTY SEVEN CONTINUES.
TO ALLOW PHARMACISTS TO FILL
SYRINGES WITHOUT A PRESCRIPTION
AND HELP PREVENT THE SPREAD OF
HIV AND HEPATITIS C. THE BILL
EXTENDS THE SUNSET FROM MY
PREVIOUS BILL AB SEVENTEEN
FORTY THREE FOR ANOTHER FIVE
YEARS UNTIL TWENTY. TWENTY SIX
THREE JACKSON'S HELP SLOW THE
SPREAD OF HIV AND HAVE ARE.
MORE THAN TWO HUNDRED FROM
AROUND THE WORLD HAVE
CONSISTENTLY SHOWN THAT IMPROVE
SYRINGE ACCESS REDUCES THE RATE
OF SEVEN SHARING AND DISEASE
TRANSMISSION WITHOUT INCREASING
THE RATES OF DRUG USE DRUG
INJECTION OR- CRIME. THE STATE
OFFICE OF AIDS CDP AGENCY SEE
ARE ALL STRONGLY IN FAVOR OF
IMPROVE FRINGE ACCESS THROUGH
SYRINGE EXCHANGE PROGRAMS. AND
THROUGH PHARMACY SALE OF
SYRINGES. WITH THAT WE HAVE A
WITNESS QUINN BOXES FROM THE
DRUG POLICY ALLIANCE AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE
ON AB TWENTY SEVENTY SEVEN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ENTERTAINING- SO LET'S MOVE ON
TO THE WITNESSES SUPPORT- MR
GLENN BACKS FROM THE DRUG
POLICY ALLIANCE OF MODERATE IF
YOU CAN PLEASE BRING AMMAN TO
TESTIFY. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
GOING BACK AFTER DRUG POLICY
ALLIANCE. FUNDS ONE OF THE CO
SPONSORS OF THE BILL THE OTHER
CO SPONSORED ARE SAN FRANCISCO
AIDS FOUNDATION AND THE HEALTH
OFFICER'S ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA. I'LL BE VERY BRIEF
THIS IS GOOD DISEASE CONTROL
POLICY. THE SPREAD OF
POTENTIALLY DEADLY DISEASES
THAT ARE COSTLY TO TREAT THAT
CAN BE DONE AT NO COST TO
GOVERNMENT. ALSO IN SUPPORT.
CALIFORNIA PHARMACY ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA RETAILERS
ASSOCIATION. CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA SOCIETY
OF ADDICTION MEDICINE AND MANY
OTHERS THANK YOU. OKAY THANKS
VERY MUCH OF THAT LET'S HEAR
FROM OTHER WITNESSES AND
SUPPORT- THERE WAS UP IN THE
GALLERY WE SEE NO WITNESSES AT
THE GALLERY A ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. THERE'S NO WITNESSES IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY LET'S MOVE TO
THE TELEPHONIC LINE MODERATOR
PLEASE OPEN THE LINES AND CALL
FOR WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY SEVENTY SEVEN- AND
PLEASE HAVE THEM BEGIN. IF YOU
AREN'T SUPPORT FOR AB. TWENTY
SEVENTY SEVEN PLEASE PRESS THE
ONE ZERO. ENSURE YOU HAVE SIX
AND SUPPORT. OKAY. NINE ONE SIX
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
KELLY BROOK ON BEHALF OF THE
COUNTY HEALTH EXECUTIVES THAT
THE PATIENT CALIFORNIA AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
NINE ONE TWO FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. RIGHT
CENTER WITH AMERICAN COLLEGE
OBG. DISTRICT NINE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. ONE
SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
AFTERNOON DOCTOR BAND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE ROBERT TERRACE
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
SOCIETY IN MEDICINE FOR. THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS. ONE SEVEN TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. WHO NINE
PROPERTY IN. NINE ONE SEVEN TWO
PLEASE REPEAT. I CAN HEAR YOU
OKAY THIS IS GOING THE WAY WITH
RESTAURANTS AND ARMAND POPPY IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU THIS WITNESS.
LINE ONE THREE EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. DANIEL GUTIERREZ ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ATTORNEYS FOR CRIMINAL JUSTICE
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. ONE SIX THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. BACK IN DOLLARS
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
SUPPORT. TWENTY NEXT WITNESS.
YEAH ONE MOMENT PLEASE. PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT ONE ZERO. YOU DO HAVE
THREE ADDITIONAL AND SUPPORT
ONE MOMENT. ONE MOMENT. LINE
ONE SEVEN ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE SEVEN
ONE. YEAH. ONE ONE SEVEN ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. PRESS TO. PASS A NEW
DOOR WITH THE NEXT WITNESS. YES
WORK ALL TO LINE ONE FORTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. ONE THIRTY NINE ONE FOUR
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. NINE ONE FOUR FOUR
PLEASE AHEAD. GERMAN HAPPY
MUSTARD WITH THE SEPARATE
GRAYSON AND THAT'S THE BOXES
NOTED CO SPONSORING THANK YOU
TWENTY NINE NEXT WITNESS AND IF
THERE'S OTHER PEOPLE ONLINE
SOUNDS LIKE WE NEED SOME. OF
THE NEWS AND SOME PEOPLE THAT.
ONE ONE SEVEN THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. FISHING AND. ONE SEVEN
THREE PLEASE. STATE AGAIN.
PRETTY MUCH CHAIR MEMBERS
COURAGE BUYING THE COW NURSES
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. JEAN
NEXT WITNESS. AT LINE ONE SEVEN
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. ONE SEVEN SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. I'M SORRY AND GOOD
AFTERNOON HERE MEMBERS PERSONAL
TO DOS ON BEHALF OF THE CITY
AND COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NEXT WITNESS MANY MORE CHAIR
THERE ARE NO ADDITIONAL IN Q.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH RIGHT
NOW WILL MOVE TO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION- THERE'S NO LEAD
OPPOSITION IDENTIFIED SO LET'S
IS FIRST MOVED TO THE CHAMBER I
SEE NO WITNESSES AND THE
GALLERY IN OPPOSITION WAS MOVED
TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY. THERE ARE
NO WITNESSES AND ROOM TWENTY
FORTY LET'S MOVE TO THE
TELEPHONIC LINE- MODERATOR
PLEASE OPEN THE LINE- AND CALL
THE WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. TO
EIGHTY TWENTY SEVEN SEVEN. IF
YOU ARE AN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME ONE
ZERO. NO ONE IS IN Q. AT THIS
TIME OKAY THANK YOU ONE SEVEN
ONE. ONE SEVEN ONE JUST PLEASE
GO AHEAD PLEASE. GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIRMAN BRITISH ON
BACHELOR ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION RESPECTFULLY AND
OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY SEVENTY
SEVEN THANK YOU. THANK YOU ARE
THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. NOT AT THIS TIME
SIR OKAY THANK YOU. NOW THE
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. OKAY SEEING
NONE- SERVER TING I WENT THERE
SO THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD- I
HOPE THE NEXT TIME THIS BILL
ADDS THAT ARE SIMILAR BILL
COMES FOR WE COULD JUST SIMPLY
ELIMINATE THE DEADLINE DATE
INSTEAD OF KEEP EXTENDING IT
OUT CERTAINLY EXCELLENT PUBLIC
HEALTH BY APPRECIATE YOU
BRINGING FORD ENSURING THAT. WE
CAN CONTINUE THIS VERY POOR
PUBLIC HEALTH MEASURE FOR MANY
MORE YEARS- MOVING OUT SO WITH
THAT- WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND- WE
WILL WE WILL WORK ON THAT NEXT
TIME BUT THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT AND I. RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR ABOUT. OKAY THANKS VERY
MUCH- IS THERE A MOTION ON THIS
BILL. OKAY EXTENDED BY CENTER
MY NAME TO MOTIONS DO PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS- SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. CAN I CAN
I CAN SALAS AYE GONZALEZ I GROW
NO GROWTH NO HER TITLE. NO NO
SORRY NO PATERNO LEYVA HI LEYVA
AYE MELENDEZ MITCHELL. HI
MITCHELL AYE MONNING AYE
MONNING AYE RUBIO HI RUBIO AYE.
SIX OKAY THAT BILL IS OUT SIX
TWO. THE SERVER MUCH A SUMMER
TING ALL RIGHT. THE NEXT BILL
IS ACTUALLY- THIS SUMMER WOULD
HERE OKAY SO WE ACTUALLY HAVE
TWO BILLS THAT YOU'RE GOING TO
BE PRESENTING ITEM NUMBER SIX
AB TWENTY ONE HUNDRED AND THEN
ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN AB TWENTY
SIX FORTY FOUR SO WE'LL JUST
TAKE THOSE IN THAT ORDER IF
THAT'S ALRIGHT. SO LET'S GO
AHEAD WHAT ITEM NUMBER SIX AB
TWENTY ONE HUNDRED SOME NUMBER
ONE WELCOME THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS- AB TWENTY
ONE HUNDRED IS A BILL IN
RESPONSE TO A CHANGE IN- TO A
CHANGE TO MEDI CAL PHARMACY
REIMBURSEMENT IN FEE FOR
SERVICE AND THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL TO
CHANGE THE MEDI CAL. BECAUSE
THIS RESTAURANT JOB BENEFIT TO-
THE FOR SERVICE THE BILL MAKES
SEVERAL CHANGES TO ADDRESS
CURRENT PROBLEMS AN INSURER
EXISTING APPEALS RIGHTS
CONTINUE FIRST THE BILL WOULD
ENSURE PATIENT ACCESS TO
MEDICATIONS BY PROVIDING THE
DISEASE MANAGEMENT PAYMENT
BASED ON THE RESULTS OF THE
SURVEY OF PHARMACIES SECOND
WOULD PROVIDE AN INDEPENDENT
APPEALS PROCESS 4% PRESCRIPTION
DRUG IN NILES. AND THIRTY WOULD
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL DATA AS PART
OF THE BUDGET PROCESS ON HOW
WELL THE NEW PHARMACY BENEFIT%
IS WORKING THE BILL IS JOINTLY
SPONSORED BY WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY AND THE
CALIFORNIA PHARMACISTS
ASSOCIATION HAS ENJOYED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. LIKE TO
HEAR I LIKE IT HERE FOR MY
WITNESSES AND I ASK FOR YOUR
FIVE A- OKAY THANK YOU. LET'S
MOVE ON TO THE WITNESSES AND
SUPPORT- SO I HAVE HERE IS- FOR
EIGHTY TWENTY ONE HUNDRED ARE
JIM GROSS OF IT THE CALIFORNIA
PHARMACISTS ASSOCIATION AND ON
THE WAY WITH THE AWESOME CENTER
ON LAW AND POVERTY SO FOR A
MODERATOR YOU CAN TREAT PLEASE
BRING THEM ON TO LINE. YOUR
LINE IS A MUTED PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
JIM GROSS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PHARMACISTS
ASSOCIATION A CO SPONSOR- AS-
WHICH INDICATED BY DOCTOR
WOULD- THIS IS TO ADDRESS- AN
ONGOING PROBLEM WITH-
INADEQUATE REIMBURSEMENT RATES
FOR A CERTAIN HIGH COST DRUGS-
IN THE MEDICARE PROGRAM- THE
RESULTS OF EFFORTS BY THE
DEPARTMENT TO MEET FEDERAL
REQUIREMENTS- RESULTED IN A-
CIRCUMSTANCE WHERE PHARMACISTS
WERE BEING REIMBURSED FAR BELOW
COST- AS A RESULT. MANY
PHARMACIES COULD NOT- STOCK
THOSE DRUGS COULD NOT DISPENSE
THEM- TO THE POPULATION THAT IS
IN MOST NEED- THIS BILL- I CAN
COMES ABOUT AS A RESULT OF
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE DEPARTMENT
ALTHOUGH THEY ARE CURRENTLY
OPPOSED TO THE BILL- THE
MECHANISM THAT IS IN THE BILL
THAT BEING A DISEASE MANAGEMENT
PAYMENT. DID COME FROM THOSE
DISCUSSIONS AND WE ARE HOPEFUL
THAT WE CAN CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OVER THEIR
CONCERNS BUT THIS ISSUE NEEDS
TO BE ADDRESSED IMMEDIATELY-
BECAUSE IT IS ALREADY FOR SOME
PERIOD OF TIME RESULTED IN A
LACK OF ACCESS- TO THESE DRUGS
FOR THE MEDICAL POPULATION WITH
THE- ADOPTION OF CAL ARE
ACTUALLY SLIGHTLY IMPORTANT IT
WE FIX THIS. BEFORE THE
EFFECTIVE DATE OF CAL ARE
ACTUALLY SCHEDULED. FOR JANUARY
ONE THANK YOU VERY MUCH. OKAY
YOU LET'S MOVE ON TO. ANYTHING
THANK YOU PLEASE BE AN- GOOD
AFTERNOON AWAY WITH WASHINGTON
ON MON POVERTY CUT COACH BUDGET
AB TWENTY ONE HUNDRED WHICH
PROVIDE IMPORTANT CONSUMER
PROTECTION. FOR THE THIRTEEN
MILLION MEDI CAL ENROLLEES WHO
ARE AFFECTED TO RECEIVE DRUG.
DELIVERY SYSTEM AFFECTED THE
JANUARYIT'S STILL INSURED THAT
MOST YOU ALWAYS CURRENTLY
RECEIVING DRUG TO THEIR MEDI
CAL PLAN CONTINUE TO HAVE
ACCESS TO EXTERNAL APPEAL RIGHT.
THAT REQUIRE CRITICAL REVIEW.
LI NA AVAILABLE ON THIRTY FIRST
BY ONE MEDIC HOW BENEFICIARIES
ONLY ACCESS TO EXTERNAL TO ME
JUDGE WITH LEGAL NOT CLINICAL
EXPERTISE. AND THE BRITISH
OVERTURNED BY PART. MEDI CAL IN
THE LOOPBACK TO THE NEWSLETTER
WITH THE WITH A MATURE OF SIXTY
OF THE NATION'S WITHOUT IT
NOTHING. TO TODAY. IN ADDITION
THEY WILL KILEY DECISION
THERE'S NO THAT THAT MIGHT TO
ABOUT. UNDER THE CURRENT X.
APPEAL. IN MEDICAL TO HELP
ARTIE STRESS TO DO IT THE HEAD
MAKE IT EVEN MORE THAT MEDI CAL
PAY HAVE ACCESS DRUGS MY
PROTECTION PROVIDED DEL. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK HERE I VOTE.
ON THE BY PARTY BILL THAT
PASSED YEAH ASSEMBLY
UNANIMOUSLY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- WITH THAT WILL
MOVE ON TO OTHER WITNESSES AND
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL UP
GALLERY I SEE NO WITNESSES UP
IN THE GALLERY LET'S REYES
MOVED TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY. I
SEE NO WITNESSES A ROOM TWENTY
FORTY LET'S MOVE TOWARD
TELEPHONIC LINE. AND A
MODERATOR OF PLEASE OPEN THE
LINES FOR. THOSE WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. OF AB
TWENTY ONE HUNDRED. IF YOU ARE
IN SUPPORT FOR A BI TWENTY ONE
HUNDRED PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME ONE ZERO. AND SIR
YOU HAVE SIX AND SUPPORT. WE'LL
GO TO LINE ONE SEVEN EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS JENNIFER SNYDER ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
RETAILERS ASSOCIATIONAND THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF CHAIN
DRUG STORES. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. NINE ONE SEVEN ZERO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
YES MEAN PILOT ON BEHALF OF
HEALTH BACK WITH CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS
TWO ONE SIX THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. REBECCA GONZALEZ
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
SUPPORT. ONE EIGHT TWO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GEN MADDEN REPRESENT
THE CALIFORNIA RHEUMATOLOGY
LINES IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. ONE EIGHT THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NEARLY TO THE
CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC HEALTH
NETWORK IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
NEXT THIS. LINE ONE EIGHT FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO ELLIE
ARE THEY ARE DO WITH THE COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU THIS. ONE THREE ZERO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THE LIGHT YOU ON
BEHALF OF DISABILITY RIGHT
CALIFORNIA WE ARE IN THE COURT.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. ONE
EIGHT FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE
KNOWLEDGE OF ANY CALIFORNIA
CHRONIC CARE COALITION SUPPORT
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. ONE
EIGHT SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
RIGHT NOW OR REPRESENTING A
PHARMACEUTICAL RESEARCH AND
MANUFACTURERS OF AMERICA TO
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU X.
WITNESS. SURE THERE ARE NO
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES THANK YOU
AT THE TIME. OKAY WITH THAT
LET'S MOVE TO THE OPPOSITION-
THERE IS NO LEAD OPPOSITION
THAT'S INDICATED SO- FIRST WILL
GO TO THE ACT CHAMBER GALLERY.
AND I SEE NO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION THERE LET'S MOVE TO
ROOM TWENTY FORTY. THREE NO
WITNESSES- AND BRING TWENTY
FORTY LET'S NOW MOVE TO THE
TELEPHONIC LINE- MODERATE
PLEASE OPEN THE LINES AND CALL
FOR WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO
AB TWENTY ONE HUNDRED. IF YOU
ARE IN OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY
ONE HUNDRED PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME ONE ZERO IF
YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION. NO ONE
HAD CUED UP OKAY SEEING HERE-
NO ONE IN OPPOSITION TESTIFYING
ON THE BRING IT BACK TO CHAMBER
THEIR OR COMMENTS COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. OKAY SEEING NONE BUT
GETS SAYS HER DAUGHTER. I JUST
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD AND-
BY PAUL HIM FOR ALL ITS WORK.
AND I'M HAPPY TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL TODAY OKAY IS THAT ALSO
MOTION. IS THAT ALSO A MOTION.
I'D MAKE THEM TO MOVE THE
MOTION WITH THE BILL ALL RIGHT
OKAY- SEVERAL THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL FORTY
HARD WORK ON THIS I THINK IT'S
VERY IMPORTANT- IN TERMS OF
MAKING SURE THAT WE MAKE OUR
MEDI CAL PHARMACY SYSTEM WORK
AND SO WITH THAT WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE. RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
ABOVE OKAY THANKS VERY MUCH
NUMBER WOULD- THIS BILL IS BEEN
MOVED BY CENTER TADO- SO AGAIN
THIS IS AB TWENTY ONE HUNDRED-
BUT CENTER TADO THE MOTION IS
TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
PAN HI CAN HI GONZALEZ I AND
SALAS I GROW. I GROW BY HER
TITLE HI THE TOTAL AYE LEYVA HI
LEYVA AYE MELENDEZ MITCHELL ALL
RIGHT MITCHELL AYE MONNING NINE
MONEY I RUBIO HI RUBIO I. OKAY
THE BILL IS OUT EIGHT ZERO ALL
RIGHT SO THE NEXT BILL IS
ACTUALLY EIGHT ITEM NUMBER
FIFTEEN AB TWENTY SIX FORTY
FOUR- SO PLEASE BEGIN
PRESENTATION. THANK YOU AGAIN
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS I'M
PRESENTING AB TWO SIX FOUR FOUR
IT DOES TWO THINGS IT REQUIRES
A DURING A DECLARE EMERGENCIES
SUCH AS THE COPA NINETEEN
PANDEMIC WE ARE CURRENTLY IN A
SKILLED NURSING FACILITY A TO
REPORT EACH COMMUNICABLE
DISEASE RELATED DEATHS RELATED
RELATED DEATH TO THE STATE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
WITHIN TWENTY FOUR HOURS. AND
IN TURN REQUIRES STATE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH TO
MAKE THE DATA THE TOTAL NUMBER
OF DEATHS AVAILABLE ON ITS
WEBSITE ON A WEEKLY BASIS ALL
THESE FACILITIES AND THE PH
ALREADY DOING THIS PURSUANT TO
FEDERAL REQUIREMENTS PUT IN
PLACE DURING THE STATE OF
EMERGENCY THIS BILL. CODIFIES
THAT. WE DON'T NEED TO REINVENT
THE PROCESS EACH TIME AN
EMERGENCY IS DECLARED. REQUIRES
NURSING HOMES TO HAVE A FULL
TIME INFECTION PREVENTION IS. I
WILL BE A MANY KNOW OUR
LANGUAGE THAT CLARIFIED LONG
TERM CARE OMBUDSMAN ABILITY TO
ENTER SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES DUE TO AND DURING AN
EMERGENCY. I DO TO THE CHAIRS
CONCERNS. THERE ARE ALREADY
VARIOUS REQUIREMENTS SETTINGS
ARE THE EXISTING LAW FOR HOW
AND WHEN A DEATH IS REPORTED
DEPENDING UPON THE
CIRCUMSTANCES. AND CO IN
NINETEEN THE S. R. REGARD BEING
REPORTED BUT I'M CONCERNED
THEY'RE NOT BE REPORTED AS
TIMELY AS ACCURATELY AS THEY
COULD BE. APPROXIMATELY ONE
THIRD OF KOBE DESTIN CALIFORNIA
ARE ATTRIBUTED TO NURSING HOME
RESIDENTS AND STAFF. WE NEED TO
ENSURE THAT THESE FACILITIES
ARE DOING EVERYTHING THEY CAN
TO PREVENT INFECTIONS PART OF
SUMMER TO SEE THEY WERE ONLY
REQUIRED TO HAVE A PART TIME
INFECTION PREVENTION IS.THIS
BILL SIMPLY CODIFIES EMERGENCY
REQUIREMENT TO HAVE THAT TO
THAT POSITION BE A FULL TIME
POSITION. NURSING HOME
RESIDENTS ARE SOME OF OUR MOST
VULNERABLE CALIFORNIANS THEY
DESERVE TO BE PROTECTED. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
OKAY THANKS VERY MUCH SUMMER
WOULD SO WE'RE NOT GOING TO
MOVE TO THE WITNESS AND SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY SIX FORTY FOUR WE
HAVE. LEASE A COLEMAN FROM THE
CALIFORNIA LONG TERM CARE
OMBUDSMAN ASSOCIATION. OF
MODERATORS TO PLEASE BRING YOUR
ON THE LINE TO TESTIFY IN.
SUPPORT. BUT I HATE YOUR LINE
IS I'M YOU DAY. GO AHEAD YOUR
LINE IS ON MUTE IT. FOR PLEASE
TELL ME OF YOUR PHONE. OKAY
CHAIRED DO NOT BELIEVE SHE S
ON THE LINE OKAY- ALL RIGHT SO
I GUESS WILL THEN WE'LL JUST GO
AHEAD AND MOVE FORWARD THEN-
SO- WE'LL HEAR FROM OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF- AGAIN
AT TWENTY SIX FORTY FOUR WILL
GO TO THE GALLERY- I SEE NO
WITNESSES IN THE GALLERY LET'S
MOVE TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY. SEE
NO WITNESSES IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY LET'S MOVE TO THE
TELEPHONIC LINES SO MODERATOR
PLEASE OPEN THE LINES FOR
WITNESSES WHO WISH TO. EXPRESS
THEIR SUPPORT FOR AB TWENTY SIX
FORTY FOUR. IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT FOR A BI TWENTY SIX
FORTY FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONE ZERO.
AND YOU DO HAVE ONE PERSON
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT. PLEASE
BEGIN. ONE THIRTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
LISA COLEMAN THE CALIFORNIA
LONG TERM CARE BUT BUT IT DOES
FEATURE. WE USED TO SUPPORT AB
TWENTY SIX FORTY FOUR THIS BILL-SEEKS TO ADDRESS SEVERAL TITLE
ISSUES RELATED TO SKILLED
NURSING FACILITY BUT FOR THE
SAKE OF TIME I WANT TO POINT
OUT HOW THE BILL WILL
STREGTHEN PRESIDENT ALI SHARE.
WITH THE REQUIREMENT OF A FULL
TIME INFECTION PREVENTION
SPECIALIST. LOCAL LONG TERM
CARE OMBUDSMAN PROGRAMS HAVE
BEEN WITH THREE YEARS FOR
COMPLIANCE WITH INFECTION
PREVENTION PROTOCOLS AND LEAVE.
FAILURES HAVE PUT RESIDENTS AT
UNNECESSARY RISK. EVEN BEFORE
KEVIN NINETEEN CITY PH REPORTED
THAT TWO THOUSAND AND THAT IN
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN.
INFECTION PREVENTION AND
CONTROL WITH THE FOR SINGLE
OFTEN RECORDED FEEL NURSING
FACILITY VIOLATION. WALLET HERE
TOO GOOD INFECTION PREVENTION
MEASURESIS THE RESPONSIBILITY
OF ALL STAFF. WITH THE
DESIGNATION OF A POINT PERSON
THAT PERSON OR TEAM OF PEOPLE
DâN BECOME RESPONSIBLE FOR
EDUCATING AND MONITORING THE
FACILITIES FOR COMPLIANCE.
UTILIZING AN INTERNAL STAFF
PERSON MEANS IT COMES AT A
PRICE. ACROSS ALL INDUSTRIES
INHERENT OUTCOMES ARE AN
INHERENTLY BETTER OUTCOMES ARE
CHEAT AND HE CAME. ENTITY HAVE
SKIN IN THE GAME. AMEND THAT
MUCH MORE SO THAN LOOKING TO
SURVEY TO ENFORCE. REGULATIONS
BUT WE ARE VERY EXCITED ABOUT
THE BILL AND WE ENCOURAGE THE
COMMITTEE TO SUPPORT AB TWENTY
SIX FORTY FOUR. OKAY THANK YOU.
SO THAT WAS THE TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT AS OR ANY OTHER. PEOPLE
ON THE LINE IN SUPPORT. IF YOU
ARE IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. MAKE SURE
YOU DO HAVE TO IN Q. ONE MOMENT
PLEASE THANK YOU. WELCOME TO A
LINE ONE EIGHTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BUT AFTERNOON DONNA
THANKS FOR PUTTING THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS WE ARE AT THE FOR
THE BILL I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
TRADITIONAL TRAINING
REQUIREMENTS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS. THERE'S NO
ONE ELSE THANK YOU AT THIS TIME
OKAY THANK YOU ALL RIGHT LET'S
MOVE THEN TO OPPOSITION SO WELL
WE HAVE. ON THE LEAD OPPOSITION
JENNIFER SNYDER FROM THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
HEALTH FACILITIES SO PLEASE
BRING YOUR ON THE LINE TO.
PROVIDE US MILLION OPPOSITION.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS JENNIFER
SENATOR THEY HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA SITUATION HEALTH
FACILITIES. I WHICH REPRESENTS
OVER NINE EXCLUSIVELY WILL
CALIFORNIA. WE HAVE AN OPPOSED
THE MOST AMENDED POSITION ON
AB. TWENTY SIX FORTY FOUR BUT
WE VERY MUCH THANK THE AUTHOR
AND STAFF. FOR WORKING WITH US
ON THIS BILL- AND WERE
GENERALLY SUPPORTIVE OF MOST OF
THE KEY ELEMENTS THE BILL
FIRST. WE AGREE THAT NURSING
FACILITY SHOULD REPORTING
SUSPECTED DEATH. TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
THEY CURRENTLY REPORTS THESE
DEATH TO THE DEPARTMENT CODE
NINETEEN DEATH TO THE- AND WE-
THE MOST RECENT AMENDMENT THAT
MAKE SURE THAT THEY ARE
SUSPECTED. A CO GOOD NINETEEN
THAT- SECOND WE AGREE THAT OUR
CAPABILITY SHOULD HAVE A
DEDICATED HEALTHCARE
PROFESSIONALS OR PROFESSIONALS
THAT TAKE ON THE RESPONSIBILITY
OF INFECTION CONTROL. AT TO
ENSURE YOUR COMPLETE DAPPER
PRICKLY TRAINED AND HAVE THE
APPROPRIATE PP ON HAND. I
UNDERSTAND THAT MAKE HAVE BEEN
AN UNPRECEDENTED ONE FOR
MEMBERS HEALTHCARE WORKERS THE
PATIENT'S FAMILY. WE HAVE
LEARNED AND CONTINUE TO LEARN
MANY BEST PRACTICES THAT OUR
CORPORATE IT INTO TWENTY SIX
FORTY FOUR. AND WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE AUTHORS GOOD
WORK IN THIS REGARD. I'M CAPS
HAD REQUESTED AND THAT THE BILL
BE AMENDED TO REQUIRE THAT THE
OMBUDSMAN OR ANY OTHER STATE
REGULATORS INTERNATIONAL
BECAUSE HE KEPT ON A REGULAR
BASIS. AND BOTH NURSING HOME
STAFF AND PATIENTS ARE BEING
TESTED REGULARLY AND WE KNOW
THAT THIS IS A CRUCIAL
COMPONENT TO ADDRESSING THE AND
NOT SPREAD AT THE COPA NINETEEN
VIRUS. WE WELCOME ANY CONTINUED
DISCUSSION ON THE ISSUE WITH
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND EAT.
WORK WITH NURSING AND ON THE
CRUCIAL ISSUE FOR AT YOUR ASIAN
IN CALIFORNIA THANK YOU. OKAY
THANK YOU RIGHT LET'S NOW MOVE
ON OTHER WITH AND I TO EIGHTY
TWO SIX FORTY FOUR WITH TO THE
GALA I SEE NO WITNESS AND THE
GAL LET'S MOVE TO ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. I SEE NO WITNESSES IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY LET'S MOVE TO
THE TELEPHONIC LINES MODERATOR
PLEASE OPEN THE LINES TO
WITNESSES WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY SIX
FORTY FOUR. IF YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION TO A. B. TWENTY SIX
FORTY FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME ONE ZERO.
THERE YOU HAVE ONE IN
OPPOSITION WILL GO TO THE LINE
OF ONE THREE ZERO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YOUR PHONE ONE THREE
ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON I THINK THAT MIGHT BE
MIGHT CALL MINE THEN WE ARE
ACTUALLY IN SUPPORT OF THE
WHITE DIEM ON BEHALF OF
DISABILITY RIGHT CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU OKAY THANK YOU SO
WILL WITNESSES REPORT. IS THERE
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION I AM NOT WELL. IT
DIDN'T WORK OKAY YES. THE
DISPLAY RISES IN SUPPORT ARE
THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION WHICH TO TESTIFY ON
THE LINE. NO ONE ELSE IS ON THE
LINE PLEASE GO AHEAD OKAY-
WITHOUT LET'S BRING YOU BACK IS
THERE ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE MEMBERS OF THE MAKE
NOTE THAT CENTER GROVE HAS
MOVED THE BILL. OKAY SAYING NO
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS- AGAIN A
SIMILAR WOULD I WANT THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR WORKING LIKE STAFF
AND PREVIEW TAKING THE
AMENDMENT WOULD JUST HAVE WORK
OUT SOME THINGS HERE- BUT
CERTAINLY EXTREMELY POOR BILL
AND COVET BUT ALSO THINKING
AHEAD OF KOBE TO WHAT WAS
HAPPENING PLACE- BUT THAT WOULD
LIKE TO CLOSE. RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR I'VE OF. EXCELLENT ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU- SO. THE MOTION
IS. DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS SUBDIVIDE. A
SENATOR GROW AGAIN THIS IS BILL
AB TWENTY SIX FORTY FOUR-
SECURITIES CALL THE ROLL. PAN
HI CAN I CAN SALAS HI GONZALEZ
I GROW I GROUP I HER TITLE HI
THE TOTAL AYE LEYVA. HI LEYVA
AYE MELINDA'S. MITCHELL HI
MITCHELL AYE MONNING NINE MONEY
IN AYE RUBIO AYE RUBIO AYE.
OKAY THAT BILLS L. EIGHT ZERO
ALL RIGHT AND THEN A SUMMER
WOULD I UNDERSTAND YOU ARE ALSO
PRESENTING ITEM NUMBER SIXTEEN
AB TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY ONE
BEHALF OF THE SELLER IN THIS
AREA YES ALL RIGHT PLEASE AGAIN
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND ON ON BEHALF OF SO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER IN THIS AREA
AND I'M HAPPY TO PRESENT AB
TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY ONE. THIS
BILL SIMPLY EXTENDS A SUNSET ON
THE CALIFORNIA PARKINSON'S
WRITTEN DISEASE REGISTRY UNTIL
JANUARY ONE TWENTY TWENTY SIX
OVER A HUNDRED AND SIXTEEN
THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS HAVE
PARKINSON'S DISEASE ACOSTA FIVE
POINT EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY. AFTER BECOMING
OPERATIONAL IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN.
HAS COLLECTED THE DATA THE-
REGISTRY HAS COLLECTED OVER
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED TWENTY
THOUSAND LIKE TRONIC RECORDS
INFORMED REPORTING PARTNERSHIPS
WITH HEALTH GROUPS LIKE SUTTER
KAISER DIGNITY. SCRIPTS AND
STANFORD HEALTH WHICH ALLOW THE
AUTOMATIC. CONFIDENCE DATE
PATIENT INFORMATION INTO THE
STATE'S DATABASE SO THERE IS NO
BURDEN ON A POSITION. HI ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE- TODAY WITH ME
VIRTUALLY IN SUPPORT IS THE
MICHAEL J. FOUNDATION MICHAEL
J. FOX FOUNDATION A SPONSOR OF
THE BILL. OKAY THANKS VERY MUCH
DECEMBER WOULD SO- WE HAPPENS-
SUPPORT NEAT SO OFTEN THE
MICHAEL J. FOX FOUNDATION AND
YOURS MADRE RICKY PLEASE SEE IF
HE'S ON THE LINE I HEARD HE
HASN'T THAT IS NOT ONLINE YET
BUT PLEASE CHECK. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. EXCELLENT THANKS SO MUCH
LATE SO ON THE AFTER THE
MICHAEL J. FOX FOUNDATION FOR
PARKINSON'S RESEARCH I
APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT TO
CREATE THIS PROGRAM IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN AND TO EXTEND THE
SUNSET LAST YEAR WITH UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. THE
REGISTRY HAD COLLECTED OVER TWO
HUNDRED TWENTY THOUSAND LIKE
CHRONIC RECORDS BY FORMING
REPORTING PARTNERSHIPS WITH
HELP GROUPS LIKE SUTTER KAISER
DIGNITY SCRIPT STANFORD HELP
AND MANY OTHERS SO THAT THE
CONFIDENTIAL PATIENT DATA IT
AUTOMATICALLY SENT FROM THE
POSITIONS OFFICE TO THE STATE
WITH NO IMPACT TO THE DOCTOR.
8290% OF THE PATIENT DATA IS
AUTOMATICALLY SENT TO THE STATE
SO WOULD- DEPARTMENTS MAKING
GREAT PROGRESS THERE. WE
BELIEVE THE REGISTRY NEEDS TO
BE CONTINUED FOR MANY REASONS
OTHER ONGOING DATA CAN BE
PROVIDED TO RESEARCHERS IN THE
MEDICAL COMMUNITY. THE DATA
WILL HELP IDENTIFY HIGH RISK
GROUPS SUPPORT PATIENTS STUDIED
AND SERVE AS A VALUABLE DATA
RESOURCE TO PREVENT AND UP TO
BELIEVE MANAGE PARKINSON'S
DISEASE. TO MORE ACCURATELY
DETERMINE PARKINSON'S HOT SPOT
LOCATIONS THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
CAN TO HELP THE TERM THAT
CERTAIN REGIONS OF THE STATE TO
USE MORE PESTICIDES BASED ON
CALIFORNIA'S PESTICIDE REGISTRY
HAVE HIGHER INCIDENCE OF
PARKINSON'S. STUDIES HAVE SHOWN
A CORRELATION BETWEEN HIGHER
PESTICIDE USE AND INCREASES AND
PARKINSON'S CASES. AND IMPROVE
OUR UNDERSTANDING OF THE LINK
BETWEEN PARKINSON'S IN MILITARY
SERVICE AND A LARGER PORTION OF
THE VETERANS COMMUNITY HAS
PARKINSON'S COMPARED TO THE
GENERAL POPULATION. AND THE
REGISTRY PROVIDE THE LARGEST
AMOUNT OF DATA TO THE CENTERS
FOR DISEASE CONTROL AND
PREVENTION'S NATIONAL
NEUROLOGICAL CONDITIONS
SURVEILLANCE SYSTEM WHICH IS
WORKING WITH RESEARCHERS AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL TO IMPROVE
TREATMENTS AND FIND CURES. FOR
ALL THESE REASONS WE APPRECIATE
YOUR SUPPORT ON AB TWENTY
TWENTY ONE THANK YOU OKAY
THANKS VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF.
THIS BILL WILL MOVE FOR THE
GALLERY. I SEE NO WITNESSES AT
THE GALLERY LET'S MOVE TO ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. THE DOW WITNESSES
AROUND TWENTY FORTY LET'S MOVE
TO THE TELEPHONIC LINE
MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE
LINES. FOR WITNESSES WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY ONE. IF YOU
ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
EIGHT TWENTY ONE PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO. ONE ZERO IF YOU ARE
IN SUPPORT. AND YOU HAVE FOUR
LINES. ONE MOMENT PLEASE THANK
YOU. ONE ONE TWO FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. OKAY AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS. TO ONE ZERO
ONE MOMENT PLEASE. A MOMENT
PLEASE. LOOKS COUPLE. I THINK
IT'S CLEAR TO BE AROUND SOMEONE
LIKE. THANK. NINE ONE NINE
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE
IS OPEN ONE NINE SEVEN. WHAT'S
MY LINE ONE NINE SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS DOCTOR
ALLEN WILL I AM A PROFESSOR
NEUROLOGISTS PARKING IN THE
DATABASE LOOKED AT UCLA
ADDITION INFORMATICS MEMBER OF
AMERICAN ACADEMY OF
NEUROLOGISTS PRACTICE
MANAGEMENT TECHNOLOGY
SUBCOMMITTEE IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS. NINE ZERO
ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD TWO ZERO
ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. TWO
ZERO ZERO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
THIS IS A GRAND I EVER PROGRAM
MANAGERS THAT AFFAIRS AT THE
AMERICAN ACADEMY OF NEUROLOGY-
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. LINE TWO ZERO ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN TWO ZERO ONE. TWO ZERO ONE
OPEN. SO GREEN WENT FROM UC
MERCED. AND DYING FORTY. THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS. LINE ONE ZERO
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. ONE ZERO TWO. PLEASE
GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO MY NAME IS PATRICIA
MANNING AND THE STUFF OF POP
AND THANKS FOR LETTING YOU
AMEND THAT THE LARGEST SAN
DIEGO AND VENTURA COUNTY
HAPPENS AT THE POST OAK I'M
HERE ON BEHALF TO AND I DID OF
IT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU THANKS.
THANK YOU THERE ARE NO
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES. IT'S VERY
MUCH A LET'S MOVE TO WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION I DO NOT. SEE A
LEAD OPPOSITION LISTED SO LET'S
MOVE FIRST OF THE GALLERY- I
SEE NO WITNESSES IN THE GALLERY
TO EXPLAIN OPPOSITION SOME
MOVED TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY. NO
WITNESSES IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
LET'S MOVE TO THE TOP PHONIC
LINE MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE
LINES IN CALL FOR WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO AB. TWENTY EIGHT
TWENTY ONE. IF YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY EIGHT
TWENTY ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME ONE ZERO. AND
YOU DO HAVE ONE PERSON CUED UP
ONE MOMENT PLEASE. NO COST TO
LINE ONE NINE EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ONE NINE EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE
NINE EIGHT PLEASE ON MUTE YOUR
PHONE AT THIS TIME YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. ONE NINE EIGHT WE CANNOT
HEAR YOU PLEASE ON MUTE YOUR
PHONE IF YOUR LINE IS MUTED.
OKAY WELL LET'S MOVE ON IF
THERE ARE ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION. NO ONE ELSE IS
THANK YOU OKAY RIGHT THANKS
VERY MUCH- LET'S BRING YOU BACK
HERE ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS. SAYING
NINE- SUMMER WOULD THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR PRESENTING THIS BILL
ME HALF AS A MEMBER DOES AREA
AND CERTAINLY A VERY IMPORTANT
PROGRAM ONCE YOU CONTINUE
BEYOND THAT THE END OF THIS
YEAR. I WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR OF A-
THANK YOU IS THERE A MOTION AS
CENTER MINING YEAH BILLS TO
SPEAK OKAY MOTION VERSION FROM
CENTER MINORITY SO THIS IS AB
TWENTY TWENTY ONE THE MOTION IS
TO PASS. TO APPROPRIATIONS MOVE
BY CENTER MINING SECTOR THESE
CALL THE ROLL. HAN HI. CAN I
CAN. HI AND I GROW I GREW AYE
HER TITLE HI HER TITLE I LEAVE.
HI LEYVA AYE MELINDA'S MITCHELL
OKAY MITCHELL AYE MONNING HI
MONNING AYE RUBIO. AYE RUBIO
AYE. OKAY THIS BILL TWENTY
TWENTY ONE IS ABOUT EIGHT ZERO
THANK YOU. GLAZER MUCH SAN
RELATED THANK YOU.ALL RIGHT
OUR NEXT ITEM IS ITEM NUMBER
TWELVE- BY AB TWENTY THREE
SIXTY BY SUMMER MAIENSCHEIN
AND- CENTER MITCHELL BE
PRESENTING. THANK YOU
RESILIENT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER CHAIRMAN ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MANSION I'D
LIKE TO ACCEPT THE AMENDMENTS
AS REFLECTED IN THE ANALYSIS
AND- THANK COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
THEIR WORK ON THIS BILL. AB
TWENTY THREE SIXTY WOULD
REQUIRE HEALTH PLANS TO
ESTABLISH A DOCTOR TO DOCTOR
MENTAL HEALTH CONSULTATION LINE
FOR DOCTORS TREATING. ITEM IN
PEDIATRIC PATIENTS PERRY PARDON
IN PEDIATRIC PATIENTS THE
CONSULTATION LINE WOULD
UTILIZED TELEHEALTH OPTIONS TO
CONNECT PRIMARY CARE PROVIDERS
WITH THE MIDDLE HEALTH
CLINICIAN WHO CAN PROVIDE
ADVICE ON DIAGNOSIS AND
DEVELOPING AN EVIDENCE BASED
TREATMENT PLAN. WHY THIS IS
NECESSARY ONE IN FIVE WOMEN
WILL BE AFFECTED BY MENTAL
HEALTH DISORDER DURING
PREGNANCY OR WITHIN THE FIRST
YEAR GIVING BIRTH THE
PREVALENCE OF MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES IN CHILDREN IS RISING.
DESPITE EVIDENCE THAT EARLY
DIAGNOSIS AND TREATMENT
MITIGATES MORE SERIOUS NO
HEALTH ISSUES. PART OF MOTHERS
AND CHILDREN STILL FACE GAPS IN
RECEIVING APPROPRIATE CARE.
BECAUSE THERE IS A CONTINUING
SHORTAGE OF PSYCHIATRISTS
MIDDLE HEALTH PROVIDERS PRIMARY
CARE PHYSICIANS ARE ON THE
FRONT LINES OF DIAGNOSING AND
TREATING MENTAL HEALTH ISUES
YET MANY LACK THE SPECIALIZED
EDUCATION OR EXPERIENCE. BEFORE
THE PANDEMIC PERRY PART OF
MOTHERS AND CHILDREN WERE
ALREADY AT HIGHER RISK FOR
DEVELOPING MENTAL HEALTH
CONDITIONS THESE EXISTING RISK
FACTORS ARE NOW COMPOUNDED IN
INTENSIFIED BY FEAR UNCERTAINTY
AND ISOLATION FROM CRITICAL
NETWORKS OF SUPPORT. IN FACE OF
THIS CRISIS WE MUST TAKE ACTION
TO SUPPORT PROVIDERS IN
BUILDING THEIR CAPACITY TO
DIAGNOSE AND TREAT THE
DISORDERS AND PROVIDE
APPROPRIATE MENTAL HEALTH
TREATMENT FOR PATIENTS. ON THE
PHONE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. ON
INCLUDES- AMBER GINSBURG A
MOTHER OF TWO AND GOVERNING
COUNCIL MEMBER OF MIDDLE
MATERNAL MENTAL HEALTH NOW. AND
DOCTOR PATRONS STEIN BUSHEL SO
SEE PROFESSOR OF PSYCHIATRY YOU
CFS. THANKS FOR MUCH- CENTER
MITCHELL LET'S NOW MOVE TO OUR
WITNESSES TESTIFYING SOME POOR
AND SUPPORT THE AND THAT'S IT-
AMBER GINSBURG AND DR PETRA-
STEIN BUSHEL- SO MODERATE
PLEASE BRING THEM ON THE LINE
TO BEGIN YOUR TESTIMONY
STARTING WITH AMBER GINSBURG.
CAROLINA DONE MIDDAY. HI MY
NAME IS EVER AGAIN FOR ANOTHER
TWO AND I SIT ON THE GOVERNING
COUNCIL MATERNAL MENTAL HEALTH
THANK YOU FOR HEARING MY- MONEY
ON. L. EXACTLY TWENTY WEEKS
PREGNANT I WOKE UP IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE NIGHT A MASSIVE I
THOUGHT I WOULD DIE. I HAD
THREE MORE THAT NIGHT AND THEY
KEPT GOING. AFTER THREE DAYS OF
NOT SLEEPING I ENDED UP IN THE
ER AND I FELT CREEPY AND HELP.
YOUR DOCTOR SAID THAT BECAUSE I
WAS PREGNANT SHE DID NOT GIVE
ME ANYTHING SHE TOLD ME TO GO
HOME AND RELAX. THE PANIC
ATTACKS CONTINUED AND WORKING
AND TURN FOR MY TWO YEAR OLD
BEGIN YOUR IMPOSSIBLE. I WAS
AFRAID TO SLEEP AND I BECAME
AFRAID OF THE NIGHT. THROUGHOUT
THE SECOND HALF OF MY PREGNANCY
I CONTINUE CARRIER PRACTICAL
FIVE PROVIDER. I ALSO FOUGHT
SOUGHT TO HIGH RISK OB THAT
THERE. NO ONE KNEW WHAT TO DO.
AS THE DAYS AND WEEKS AND
MONTHS WENT ON I CONTINUE
DIFFICULT FOR MORE PROVIDERS
WITHIN A LOT. A STICKER AND
BECAME MORE HOPELESS MY BABY
AND I WERE NOT GAINING ANY
WEIGHT. I AND EIGHT THIRTY FOUR
WEEKS MY PROVIDERS FOR THE
FIRST TIME THE GESTURE LIKE ON
AN ANTI DEPRESSANT. THEY SAID
THAT EVEN THOUGH I WAS
SUFFERING PERSISTENT PANIC
ANXIETY THEY WEREN'T SURE IF IT
WOULD WORK. AND I TOLD THEM I
WASN'T GONNA TAKE SOMETHING
THAT JUST DIDN'T FEEL CONFIDENT.
I'M SORRY YOUR SUFFERING- BUT I
WOULDN'T LET MY LIFE TAKEN
SSRI. A LITTLE HIGH RISK OB
TOLD ME. THAT AFTER A WHILE
HE'S CLOSE I JUST WENT ON.
AFTER MY BABY WAS BORN I GOT
ONE GREAT KIND OF SWEET. AND
ALL. I WOULD JOHN I SEE
PREGNANCY WEEK DAYS AFTER
GIVING BIRTH WITHIN TWO WEEKS.
I FINALLY FOUND AN EXPERT ON
CARRYING ON MATERNAL MENTAL
HEALTH. TWO WEEKS LATER I WAS
ON MEDICATION STILL SAFELY
NURSING MY BABY AND ON THE ROAD
TO RECOVERY IT TOOK ME ONE
EXPERTS A RESOURCE LIKE THIS
WOULD HAVE SAVED ME I'M SO GLAD
WE NOW THE PRENATAL MENTAL
HEALTH SCREENING TOOL BUT WE
HAVE THE EXPERTISE TO HELP WILL
BE DEFINED WHAT THE NEXT STEP
SHOULD BE WE HAVE AN UNFINISHED
RESOURCE. I CAN'T IMAGINE THE
ADDITIONAL THREAT FROM PREGNANT
POST PARTUM WHEN ENTERING FOR
YOU BABY DURING THE CALL THAT.
NOW MORE THAN EVER WE NEED THIS
TOOL. I URGE YOU TO SUPPORT
EIGHTY TWENTY THREE FIFTY
WITHOUT HESITATION. DATING ARE
OVERBURDENED HEALTHCARE AND
MONEY. IN OUR CURRENT FUTURE
GENERATIONS OF MOTHERS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU LET'S MOVE ON
TO- DOCTOR PETRUS TIME BUCKLE.
SHOW FOR HELLO MY NAME HELLO MY
NAME IS DR PETER UNGAR SO I'M
THE DIRECTOR OF THE UCSF
CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL CHILD AND
ADOLESCENT PSYCHIATRY PORTALS
WE CURRENTLY PROVIDE
COMPLICATIONS THAT PRIMARY CARE
PROVIDERS IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA COUNTY. THE JOURNAL
MENTAL HEALTH DISORDERS IMPACT
ONE IN FIVE LEVELS SIMILARLY
ONE IN FIVE CHILDREN WITH
MATHEMATICA ESTIMATED ECONOMIC
COST TO CALIFORNIA TWO POINT
FOUR BILLION DOLLARS A YEAR AND
NATIONAL ECONOMIC. CONTRA AND
TWENTY THOUSAND DOLLARS YEAR.
THANK YOU. THE STORY HAVE A
MENTIONED COMPLEX MENTAL HEALTH
DELIVERY. WITH SEVERE MENTAL
HEALTH PROVIDER SHORTAGES
INCLUDING PSYCHIATRISTS. ARE
SYSTEMIC MOTHERS AND FAMILIES
SEARCHING FOR CARE AND THEN
MUCH LOOKING MOMENT. AB TWENTY
THREE SIXTY PROVIDE BETTER WAY
MODELED AFTER THE EVIDENCE
BASED NOTHING TO THE CHILD
PSYCHIATRY ACCESS PROGRAM. GET
THAT PROGRAM AB TWENTY THREE
SIXTY WOULD PROVIDE PRIMARY
HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS WHO CARE
FOR CHILDREN AND PREGNANT WOMEN
AND PST PARTUM WOMEN THE
ABILITY REPUBLICAN MENTAL
HEALTH CARE PROFESSIONALS.
INCLUDING OUR PETITIONS AND
OTHER SPECIALISTS. CONSULT WITH
A HIGH INTEREST ABOUT THIRTY
CENTS AN EVIDENCE BASED
TREATMENT OPTIONS INCLUDING.
EIGHT EIGHT DRUG TREATMENT.
PROVIDING REAL QUICK BUT
MICHAEL BY YOUR SIGNIFICANTLY
INCREASE THEIR CAPACITY TO
MANAGE BASIC DEPRESSION ANXIETY
RESERVING LIMITED AVAILABILITY
OFFICE AT. FOR MORE COMPLEX
PRESENTATIONS. RECENTLY FOR
EXAMPLE WE WERE ABLE TO CONSULT
WITH A PEDIATRICIAN PATIENT
WHAT ON THROUGH THE CRACK
BETWEEN THE REGIONAL CENTER
COOL AND THE MENTAL. AND
PHYSICAL HEALTH CARE SYSTEM. WE
THE COUNTING BY AND- CONCRETE
OF THE ACCOUNT. REVEALING A
CRACK IN THE COUNTRY OF CORN
FRENCH JOB LOSS SAID IF YOU'RE
READY HE MIGHT HAVE A WAY TO
CHECK MONTHS FOR TREATMENT
PUTTING HIS FAMILY I'M GOING TO
CALL INSIGNIA AMOUNTS JUST. FOR
LANDED DEPARTMENT. I KNOW WE
SOMETHING TO IMPROVE EARLY GUY
IT AND THE TO CARE FOR A
CALIFORNIA MOST PRECIOUS
RESOURCES MOTHERS MITCHELL. WE
CAN THAT BY EMPOWERING COULD.
LOCAL I ASK FOR YOUR WHOLE
HEARTED. EACH THREE. THANK YOU
THANKS VERY THAT'S MOVE ON TO
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF-
AT THIS BILL AT TWENTY THREE
SIXTY- WILL GO TO THE GALLERY I
SEE NO WITH AT THE GALLERY
LET'S REMOVE TO ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. I SEE NO IS THE ROOM
TWENTY FORTY A PLEASE MOVE
LET'S MOVE ON TO TELEPHONIC
LINE A MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN
THE LINES IN CALL FOR ANNIE'S
WITNESSES WHO WISH TO FIND
SUPPORT. OF AB TWENTY THREE
SIXTY. IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT
FOR AB TWENTY THREE SIXTY
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. ONE ZERO
IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT. ENTER
YOU HAVE OVER TWENTY AND
SUPPORT LOCAL TO LINE ONE SIX
THREE. NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
LINE ONE TWO FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. OKAY THE CALIFORNIA THAT
WORD ANY AMERICAN CALL YOUR
OBGYN. THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
ONE EIGHT FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI YEAH BILL COUNTY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORTING CONCEPT THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. FIND
TWO ONE FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
VANESSA KICKING ON BEHALF THE
NURSE FAMILY PARTNERSHIP AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
LINE TWO ONE SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON- CARES ON
BEHALF OF MARKET DIED SUPPORT
THANK YOU NEXT YES. ONE EIGHTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON PREFERRED TO GET US
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ACADEMY OF CHILD AND ADOLESCENT
PSYCHIATRY IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU FOR TO NEXT WITNESS.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
NEARLY TO THE CALIFORNIA PAN
ETHNIC HEALTH NETWORK IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU XO IN THIS.
ONE SIX FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THE MIND HIGH ON BECAUSE OF THE
CHILDREN QUESTION THE CARE
COALITION AND SUPPORT FOR YOU
NEXT WITNESS. ONE EIGHT FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. FINALLY THE
LAW RECOMMENDING CALIFORNIA
CHRONIC CARE COALITION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
ONE NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MICHELLE GREEN WHEN MERCED
COUNTY AND THE COURT THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. TWO TWO SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ORIGINALLY
FROM A LOT OF THE SENATE
MATERNAL MENTAL HEALTH NOW IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
ONE NINE SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME IS
ALLISON ROBINSON A CLINICAL
PSYCHOLOGIST I LIVE IN MERCED
CALIFORNIA AND I HAVE STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
LINE TWO TWO EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MY NAME IS ALLISON
SHAFFER I REPRESENTING
SUPPORTING. ERIC COUNTY WE ARE
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. WINE TWO ZERO TWO ZERO
AT ALL PLEASE GO AHEAD.
JENNIFER SURELY ON BEHALF OF
NAPA COUNTY MOM CLAD IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. LOCAL
TO I TO ONE ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. TWO ONE ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GARCIA
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT WITH
THIS. ONE MOMENT PLEASE. LOCAL
TO THE LINE OF TWO ONE ZERO
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. TWO ONE ZERO PLEASE GO
AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. TWO
ONE ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON TO DELIVER CARD THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF TWENTY
TWENTY MOMMY REPRESENT OVER
THIRTY FIVE HUNDRED FAMILIES
AND PROVIDERS IN CALIFORNIA
WHERE CC BONDURANT STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
ONE TWO TWO THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
RANDALL HAGER FOR THE
CALIFORNIA PSYCHIATRIC
ASSOCIATION THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS. TO ALL FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. IF YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS JUSTIN RAN WITH THE
CHILDREN'S PARTNERSHIP AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU THAT'S WHAT
THIS. ONE MOMENT PLEASE. ONE
NINETEEN TO PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE NINE TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD TO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. WE GOT ONLY BERNARD FROM
MERCED COUNTY MOTHER AND MENTAL
HEALTH CLINICIAN IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
TWO TWO ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS IS
KELLY O'CONNOR QUE WITH
MATERNAL BUT LOOK NOW AND THE
MOM IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. AND. ONE NINE FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THIS IS
CC TO MCCAULEY WITH MOM
CONGRESS AND STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. ONE MOMENT. FIND
TWO ONE EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. TWO ONE
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE
IS OPEN AT THIS TIME TWO ONE
EIGHT. ONE OF THE DAM I. RAN IN
MARGINALIZED COMMUNITIES IN
GREATER LOS ANGELES IN IT AND
ALL THE WORK FOR YOU KNOW HOW I
DON'T KNOW I AM A STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU THANKS WITH
THIS. ONE MOMENT PLEASE. ONE
NINE NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR
LINE IS OPEN ONE NINE NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. ONE NINE NINE
PLEASE ON YOU YOUR PHONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. I YEAH HI THIS IS
A LEAN AND ONLY- WITH LONG
CONGRESS AND I AM IN COURT.
THANK YOU IT'S WITH THIS. LINE
TWO TO ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THIS IS CHRISTINE BAKLOH BROWN
SACRAMENTO COUNTY TWENTY TWENTY
MOM AND CURRENT PPV WARRIOR.
COURT THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
NINE ONE FIVE THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN HE'S A
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS JENNIFER
ALLEY THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION AND MARRIAGE AND
FAMILY THERAPIST. WHAT WITH THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. LINE
TWO THREE THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. SH HI BARB
RELIEVER WITH THIS FEINBERG
INSTITUTE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. THREE ZERO PLEASE
GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS ALL.
AMANDA EVY A CALIFORNIA
PSYCHOLOGICAL ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. THERE'S NO ONE
ELSE THANK YOU AT THIS TIME
RIGHT THANKS VERY MUCH LET'S
NOW MOVE TO THE OPPOSITION. I
HAVE TO. PEOPLE FOR THE
TESTIFYING OPPOSITION PRESTIN
YOUNG AT THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE AND JED HAMPTON
FROM THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
HEALTH PLANS OF YOU COULD BRING
THEM ON TO THE LINE AND BEGIN
WITH- MISTER YOUNG TO PRESENT.
IN A DEPOSITION TESTIMONY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THIS IS
PRESTON YOUNG FOR THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
AND MISTER HAMPTON WAS
INTENDING TO BE LEAD I'M HAPPY
TO GO AND TO FURTHER- YOUR
DIRECTION NOW. WELL WHICHEVER
ORDER YOU WANT TO GO AND SAYS
MR HAVE TWO MONTHS AGO FIRST WE
CAN BEGIN WITH HIM. PLEASE GO
AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NOT ON.
OKAY I IS MISTER HAMPTON ON I
UNDERSTAND YOU MAY NOT BE ON.
IF THEY'RE HELPING. THIS IS.
OKAY IS MISTER HAMPTON IS DEAD
HAMPTON ON. IF NOT THEN WE'LL
MOVE ON TO PRESS AND YOUNG. ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. IT'S NOT GOING
IN. ONE MOMENT. SO I UNDERSTAND
YOU ARE ON THE LINE. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. OKAY LET'S COME. I
UNDERSTAND SO LET'S TO SKILLET
PERSON YOUNG GOING TO BRING HIM
BACK. AT LEAST WE KNOW HE'S ON
THE LINE. YES STILL HERE MISTER
SURE OTHER I DIDN'T THINK NO
COMPLICATED THING SO- I WILL BE
BRIEF IN MY- COMMENTS AGAIN
PRESS IN YOUNG FOR THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE.
AND WE'RE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED
AB TWENTY THREE SIXTY. THE
OVERARCHING CONCERN WE HAVE AND
THE REASON FOR THE OPPOSITION
AND THE IMPLEMENTATION AND
CREATION OF THE TELEHEALTH
PROGRAM THAT OUTLINED THE NAVY
TWENTY THREE SIXTY. IT
NATIONALLY TO HAVE COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE
IMPLEMENTATION AND CREATION IN
THOSE COSTS ARE GOING TO BE
PASSED ON. TO THE INSURED THE
PARTICIPANTS THE HEALTH PLAN.
THE CALIFORNIA. WHICH MEANS
INCREASE CREAMY FOR EMPLOYERS
AND EMPLOYEES IN THAT STATE SO.
MOST OF YOU HAVE LIKELY SEEN
THE COVER CALIFORNIA REPORT THE
RECENTLY CAME OUT WHERE THEY
ANTICIPATE. PREMIUMS ARE GOING
TO RUN INTO TWENTY ONE ANYWHERE
FROM 4240% BECAUSE OF THE
UNANTICIPATED COBERLY ACOSTA
FROM THIS YEAR. AND SO IF WE'RE
LOOKING AT A LANDSCAPE WHERE
PREMIUMS ARE POTENTIALLY
INCREASING UP 240% NEXT YEAR
WE'RE GONNA BE LAYERING. MORE
COST ON TOP OF THAT IT MAKES IT
VERY DIFFICULT ENVIRONMENT THAT
MUCH MORE AND MANAGE
UNMANAGEABLE PARTICULARLY THAT
WERE PURCHASED IN THE HEALTH
PLAN SO. I CERTAINLY
UNDERSTAND- THE RELEVANT TO
TIME IN THE BILL IT IS A GREAT
IDEA TO DISCUSS AT THIS POINT
HI AND- WE'RE LOOKING AT
MEDICINE FROM A DISTANCE BUT-
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE WHOLE
PICTURE. NOW MAY NOT BE THE
BEST TIME TO IMPLEMENT
SOMETHING LIKE THIS.
CONSIDERING STRUGGLING
INDIVIDUALS BUSINESSES SMALL
BENEATH THE EMPLOYEES EMPLOYERS.
ARE IN A POSITION WHERE ANY
MORE COST LAYERED ON TOP OF
WHAT THEY'RE ALREADY DEALING
WITH MAY PROVE TO BE THE END
POINT THE BREAKING POINT.
SPEAKS OKAY IT'S FOR THESE
REASONS WE ARE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE AB TWENTY THREE SIXTY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT. AND TO JUST CHECK ONE
MORE TIME TO DO WE HAVE ANYONE
FOR THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
HEALTH PLANS ON. GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR- AND MEMBERS- THAT
HIS JET HAMPTON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA THAT THEY SOMEHOW
PLAN. REPRESENTING FORTY FIVE
PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
ORGANIZATIONS. THAT
COLLECTIVELY DELIVER HEALTHCARE
SERVICES TWENTY NINE
CALIFORNIAN. REGRETTABLY WE ARE
HERE IN OPPOSITION TO DATE AB
WENTY THREE SIXTEEN PROBABLY
WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE AUTHOR
AND THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
THEIR HARD WORK ON THIS PHONE.
NUMBER PLAN STRIVE TO
INCORPORATE EVIDENCE BASED CARE
AND WE ARE CONCERNED THAT THIS
BILL WOULD PROBABLY MANDATE THE
HEALTH PLAN TO SALAS A COPY
TELEHEALTH CONSULTATION
PROGRAM. TO SPECIFIC
CLASSIFICATION OF PROVIDERS. OR
THE EVIDENCE OF THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF THESE PROGRAMS
IS LIMITED. SPECIFICALLY WE
WOULD NOTE THAT THE CALIFORNIA
HEALTH INTERVIEW PROGRAMS NOT
THAT OF AB SIXTEEN SEVENTY SIX.
A SIMILAR BILL. BERMAN THE
LIMITED EFFECTIVENESS OF
PSYCHIATRIC DECOMPOSE
GENERALLY. AND THAT THERE IS
INSUFFICIENT EVIDENCE ON THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF THE
PSYCHIATRIC BE CONTROLLED
SPECIFICALLY. FOR CHILDREN.
OPPOSE PART OF PERSONS. WE
WOULD ALSO POINT OUT THAT MAY
BE ADDITIONAL. FOR THIS BILL
THAT ARE NOT IDENTIFIED IN
BERMAN OUT THE TRADING. SEVENTY
SIX- WELL WE UNDERSTAND AT THE
COPA NINETEEN PANDEMIC HAS
FUNDAMENTALLY ALTERED NEARLY
EVERY FACET OF EVERYDAY LIFE
FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS. WE DO
WANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT THIS
BILL DID NOT RECEIVE IT ON TO
BURKE ANALYSIS AND IF HE SAID
USING A PRIOR TO BIRTH ANALYSIS
OF THE SOME OF THOSE THAT MEET
THE SPECIFIC IMPACT OF THE-
BILL. LASTLY I. ME Q. THE- THEY
ARE CONCERNED. ABOUT THE KING
OF THE IMPACT. OF BENEFIT
MANDATE SOME PREMIUM.
PARTICULARLY AS WE FACE THE
INHERENT PRESSURES ON THE BALL
AND THEY WILL MARKET. BECAUSE
THE NINETEEN PANDEMIC HAS ONLY
ELEVATED HOW CRITICAL IT IS TO
MAINTAIN AFFORDABLE PREMIUM AND
NOT A NECESSARILY DRIVE. UP THE
COST OF CARE. WE LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUING TO WORK WITH THE
OFTEN FATHERS AND THE FILM'S
RECKLESS THEY PROCESS. THANK
YOU. THANKS VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY LET'S NOW MOVE TO
OTHER WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
WILL BEGIN AT THE GALLERY- I
SEE NO WITNESSES AND THE SENATE.
GALLERY TO TESTIFY LET'S MOVE
TO ROOM TWENTY FOUR. YOU KNOW
WHAT A IS IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
LET'S MOVE THAT ARE TELEPHONIC
LINES SO- MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN
THE LINES- FOR PEOPLE WISH TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. TO AB
TWENTY THREE SIXTY. IF YOU ARE
IN OPPOSITION AB TWENTY THREE
SIXTY PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO.
YOU DO HAVE TO THANK YOU WE'LL
GO TO LINE ONE FOUR FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. TO THE MEMBERS THIS
IS KATHY. SORRY I DIDN'T GET
NUMBER TURN MEMBERS THIS IS
KATHY MONSTER WITH THE LOCAL
HEALTH PLAN THE CALIFORNIA WE
DO UNFORTUNATELY HAVE OPPOSED
THE MOTION THAT THE POSITION WE
DO APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S
OFFICE SPONSORS AND DOWN
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING ON
THE LATEST ROUND AMENDED WE
CONTINUE TO BE CONCERNED ABOUT
THE OVER USE OF PSYCHIATRISTS
WITHIN MINUTES. AND HOPE TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH AUTHORS
AND SPONSORS AT THE BILL MOVES
FORWARD THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NEXT WITNESS. LINE TWO TWO SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR ASSURING THE
QUEUE REPRESENTED THE
ASSOCIATION THAT CALIFORNIA
LIFE AND HEALTH INSURANCE
COMPANY AND OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU THANK YOU ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. THERE
ARE NO ADDITIONAL NSS RIGHT
THANK YOU LET'S MOVE IT BACK TO
OUR CHAMBER OF THE QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
OKAY SAYING NONE. A SURVEY CHOI
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR TESTIFYING
BEHALF OF SUMMER MAIENSCHEIN. I
THINK IT'S SPECIALLY IN THIS
COLD ENVIRONMENT WE KNOW THAT-
IT'S MORE CHALLENGING FOR
PEOPLE TO ACTUALLY DIRECTLY
REACH OUT TO SPECIALISTS THIS
INCLUDING MENTAL HEALTH
SPECIALISTS. THIS ROVIDES
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT TO PRIMARY
CARE DOCTORS WHO MAY ACTUALLY
BE SEEN THE PATIENT THE TIME
APPOINTED CARE AND BE SURE THAT
THEY CAN GET. BOTH MORE SYSTEMS
FOR MENTAL HEALTH THAT- AND
SUPPORTED AS PARKER DOCTORS AS
WELL AS BEING ABLE TO SORT OUT
I THINK MORE APPROPRIATE
REFERRALS AND- UNDERSCORED THE
IMPORTANCE OF THOSE REFERRALS
THIS PATIENTS. I THINK THIS IS
WHAT THIS BILL WILL DO AND
AGAIN APPRECIATE YOU PRESENTING
IT WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH A DOCTOR
PAN AND YOU TOOK THE WORDS
RIGHT OUT OF MY MOUTH THE ONE
THING I WOULD ADD IN RESPONSE
TO A- AN OPPOSITION WITNESS I
HAVE TO DO WITH THE TO BURKE
ANALYSIS. AND ACCORDING TO THE
AUTHOR UNFORTUNATELY HE
BELIEVES THE TO BURKE ANALYSIS
CONFUSED CALIFORNIA CAR TO
COUNSEL PROGRAM THE POLLS IN
THIS BILL. WITH ECON SALTS THE
IMPORTANT DIFFERENCES THAT EACH
CONSOLES PROVIDE FOR WRITTEN
CONSULTATIONS THE EMAIL FAX SIX
CETERA. AND THIS BILL PROPOSES
AN INTER ACTIVE CONSULTATION
PROVIDERS AND SPECIALIST WILL
CONDUCT VIA TELEPHONE OR VIDEO.
AND HAVE A LIVE INTERACTIVE
DISCUSSION REGARDING PROPOSED
DIAGNOSIS OR TREATMENT. FOR ALL
OF THOSE REASONS AND MORE I
ASKED FOR AND I DON'T. THANKS
VERY MUCH IS THERE A MOTION ON
THE BILL OKAY- BY CENTER
MINING. RIGHTS OF AGAIN THIS IS
AB TWENTY SIX. DOT ORG AB
TWENTY THREE SIXTY THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS BILL BY CENTER
MINING SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. PAN HI CAN NINE AND
SALAS. HI AND SALAS I GROW
GROUP NO FOR TITLE I TITLE III
LEYVA HI LEYVA AYE MELENDEZ
MITCHELL HI MITCHELL AYE
MONNING. MONNING AYE RUBIO HI
RUBIO BY. OKAY THE BILL IS OUT
SEVEN ONE THANK YOU. RIGHT NEXT
TO THE ITEM IS ITEM NUMBER
SEVENTEEN AT AB THIRTY TO FORTY
TWO BY SOME MEMBER IRWIN
PRESENTED BY CENTER RUBIO.
PLEASE BEGIN THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE HE DID TODAY
I'M PRESENTING ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTY TO FORTY TWO ON BEHALF
OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER OR WHEN THIS
IMPORTANT COMMONSENSE BILL WILL
CLARIFY THAT COUNTY SKEWS TELL
I HELD. AT THE ONE FIFTY AND
FIFTY ONE FIFTY ONE INVOLUNTARY
HOLDSEVALUATIONS BUT PREVENT
NINETEEN PANDEMIC HAS SHOWN
THAT TELL IS A SAFE AND
EFFECTIVE WAY. FOR MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS TO PROVIDE
QUALITY EVALUATIONS IN A
COMPASSIONATE WAY. AS NOTED IN
THE ANALYSIS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
IRWIN IS ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS OFFERED BY THE
SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE TO
ENSURE CONSENT AND
CONFIDENTIALITY PROTECT
PROTECTIONS ARE MATH HERE WITH
ME TODAY TO TESTIFY ARE ALEX
HAWTHORN FROM THE CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL'S ASSOCIATION AND
DANNY OFFER FROM NAMI
CALIFORNIA. THE CIVIC AND
RUBIO- SO AGAIN WE- TESTIMONY
IN SUPPORT WITH ALICE HAWTHORNE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
AND DANNY OFFER FROM THE
NATIONAL ALLIANCE ON MENTAL
ILLNESS CALIFORNIA MADRE PLEASE
BRING THEM ON THE LINE SO THEY
CAN BEGIN THEIR TESTIMONY.
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS BALLOTS AUTHORITY
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
PRIOR TO THE PANDEMIC- MET
FOURTEEN COUNTIES WERE ALREADY
UTILIZING TELEHEALTH FOR FIFTY
ONE FIFTIES ASPECTS OF THIS IS
NOT. FACT IS AN EMERGENCY ROOMS
IT'S BEEN VERY SUCCESSFUL ALL
THE DATA THAT WE HAVE BEEN
COLLECTING SHOWS THAT THE STATE
AND THE OFFICIAL TOOLS FOR
CONSUMERS AND WHAT PROVIDERS.
THE BILL IS SIMPLY A
CLARIFICATION THE TELEHEALTH
MAY BE USED FOR THE PURPOSE OF.
IF YOU WANT TO THE ASSESSMENT
EVALUATIONS FOR CROWD BECAUSE
FUNDS YOUR BILL THANK THE
AUTHOR AND RUBIO PREVENTING THE
COMMITTEE AND YOU MISTER CHAIR.
THANK YOU- IS- MISTER OFFER
AVAILABLE. PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR
LINE IS MADE AND MUTED. OKAY I
UNDERSTAND HE IS NOT ON THE
LINE. ALRIGHT WITH THAT BUT
LET'S GO AHEAD AND MOVED TO
OTHER WITNESSES AND SUPPORT- GO
TO THE GALLERY I SEE NO
WITNESSES AT THE GALLERY ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. THE NO WITNESSES
IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY SO LET'S
GO TO THE TELEPHONIC LINE A
MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE LINES
FOR WITNESSES WHO WISH TO
EXPRESS THEIR SUPPORT FOR AB
TWENTY. THIRTY TO FORTY TWO. IF
YOU ARE AND NOT PUT OUR-
SUPPORT FOR THE BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
THERE YOU DO HAVE SIX AND
SUPPORT OKAY BUT THE LINE FREE
FOR ME TO GO AHEAD. KIND AND
HOW CAN BALLOTS WITH KAISER
PERMANENTE IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU NEXT ONE NINE FOUR. PLEASE
GO AHEAD. KELLY BROKE SOME
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF PUBLIC HOSPITALS
AND HEALTH SYSTEMS AND THE
MENTOR A COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS. ONE EIGHT
FOUR PLEASE FOREHEAD. HI THIS
IS A YEAR THEY ARE TO GO WITH
THE COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT. NEXT WITNESS. ONE
THREE NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THIS IS CONNIE DELGADO ON
BEHALF OF THE DISTRICT HOSPITAL
LEADERSHIP FORUM IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. TWO THREE NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS KELLY YET
ON BEHALF OF SUTTER HEALTH INTO
PORT THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
TWO TO THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE CAN
RANDALL FOR THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION AND STRONG SUPPORT.
TWO NEXT WITNESS. THANK YOU FOR
TWO THREE SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
TWO THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN AT
THIS TIME. LINE TWO TO THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. LOCAL TO LINE UP TO FOUR
ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
BARBARA LEVER FROM THE PLAYING
BERGEN. STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. THERE'S NO ONE ELSE
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME RIGHT
THANKS VERY MUCH LET'S MOVE
DOWN TO THE OPPOSITION. INSTEAD
WE HAVE A JOHN VAN OVER FROM
THE DEPRESSION BIPOLAR SUPPORT
ALLIANCE IN OPPOSITION TO YOU
PLEASE. BRING MISTER VAN OVER
ON AT FOR JUST A. IF YOU ARE AN
ONLINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN AT
THIS TIME. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE- MY NAME IS JOHN
GRANT OVER AND I'M SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF THE DEPRESSION AND
BIPOLAR SUPPORT ALLIANCE
CALIFORNIA. AB AT THIRTY OF THE
LARGEST PEER DIRECTED
ORGANIZATION IN THE NATION THAT
FOCUSES ON THE TWO MOST
PREVALENT MENTAL HEALTH
CONDITION DEPRESSION AND
BIPOLAR. DISORDER WHICH AFFECT
MORE THAN TWENTY ONE. I DO
EVERY YEAR. IN ADDITION TO
BEING A BOARD MEMBER. THANK
CALIFORNIA I AM ALSO APPEAR. I
HAVE BI POLAR WARNING AND THE
RIGHT TO MANIC EPISODES BOTH
LED BY CATEGORY. AND IN BOTH
CASES I WENT THROUGH THE FIFTY
ONE FIFTY FIFTY ONE FIFTY ONE
PROSPECT. AND WAS PLACED ON
HOLD. BUT WE IN THE MEDIA
UNDERSTAND COPE WITH NINETEEN
PANDEMIC IS PUSHED AS THE
PARTING ALTERNATIVE METHODS. OF
PROVIDING HEALTH CARE AND
PARTICULARLY MENTAL HEALTH
CARE. WE FIRMLY OPPOSE THE USE
OF TELEHEALTH INFORMATIK CRISIS
SITUATIONS. INVOLUNTARY
COMMITTEE. WE EVEN MORE
STRONGLY OPPOSE WHICH IN OUR
JUDGMENT. AND THEIR WORK AND
WITH NO SUNSET ON THE
LEGISLATION. QUALITY OF CARE
WOULD BE ERODED THAT. WE
RECOGNIZE THAT THE PRODUCT THAT
BY THE LACK OF PROFESSIONALS
AVAILABLE TO PROPERLY EVALUATE
AND EXECUTE THE DECISION. BUT
WE DO NOT BELIEVE THAT HE
SHOULD BE THE DRIVING FORCE
BEHIND JERRY. MORE THAN
ANYTHING MENTAL HEALTH PATIENTS
NEED MORE COMPASSION AND
UNDERSTANDING ESPECIALLY IN
TIMES OF CRISIS. THIS BILL
MOVES A CRUCIAL LEVEL OF
HUMANITY WHEN PATIENTS ARE AT
THE PEAK OF TRAUMA AND
VULNERABILITY. DESPITE SUCH
INCOMPLETE LIKELY BEING THE
MOST DRAMATIC EVENT OF THESE
INDIVIDUAL AND LIKELY THEIR
FAMILY LIVES RECOVERY IS
POSSIBLE BUT IT IS MADE MORE
DIFFICULT WHEN YOU HAVE TO
ARGUE FOR A RIGHT TO THE
HOSPITAL. TO GET THEIR- WE ARE
NOT AWARE OF LEGISLATION FROM
THE HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION.
DEMANDING THAT TYPE OF
PERMANENT SWITCH FOR PATIENTS
WITH DEMENTIA OR DOUBLE WIDE.
IF WE HAD TO PAY ARE EVER GOING
TO MAKE ANY SUBSTANTIAL
PROGRESS ON MENTAL HEALTH CARE
WE MUST BEGIN TO TREAT PATIENTS
WITH BIPOLAR. SCHIZOPHRENIA
WITH THE EXACT SAME LEVEL OF
BENEVOLENT CARE IS OTHER BRING
CONDITION AND FOLLOW THE PARITY
LAWS THIS BODY HAS PREVIOUSLY
ENACTED. AT A TIME OF ENORMOUS
PROGRESS FOR HUMAN RIGHTS OF
ALL ACROSS OUR COUNTRY WELL IT
MIGHT NOT YET BE TIME FOR
MENTAL HEALTH RIGHT. WE HAVE NO
DOUBT THAT THE TIME IS COMING
AND THAT LEGISLATION LIKE THAT
WHICH DOESN'T PUT THE HEALTH
AND WELL BEING OF THE MENTAL
HEALTH PATIENT FIRST WILL SOON
BE ON THE WRONG SIDE OF
HISTORY. WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR NO VOTE ON AB
THIRTY TO FORTY TWO OR AT THE
VERY LEAST I THANK THAT
AMENDMENT. RETURNING A PRODUCT
THAT TO AN IN PERSON STATE ONCE
THE PANDEMIC OUT OF SIGHT. YOUR
TIME TODAY ON THIS IMPORTANT
MATTER. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
THANKS VERY MUCH NOW LET'S MOVE
ON TO OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO. THIRTY TO FORTY
TWO OR GO TO THE GALLERY I SEE
NO WITNESSES IN THE GALLERY
LET'S MOVE TO ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. IN A WITNESSES ROOM
TWENTY FORTY LET'S MOVE TO
TELEPHONIC LINES. MODERATOR
PLEASE OPEN THE LINES FOR
WITNESSES WHICH TO TESTIFY
AGAINST. EIGHTY THIRTY TO FORTY
TWO. YES SIR IF YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO IF YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION. THERE ARE NO ONE
HAD CUED UP OKAY THANKS VERY
MUCH ARE THERE COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. SAYING NINE CENTER
RUBIO I THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
PRESENTING- THIS BILL FROM THE
CENTER IRWIN I DO THINK THAT
THIS IS A WAY TO BE SURE E GET
TO ACTUALLY IN MANY WAYS BETTER
ACCESS- IN IN THIS A BIT
CHALLENGING IME BUT EVEN
AFTERWARDS I. KNOW THAT THE
ARTS ARE OFTEN IMPACTED AND- WE
WANT TO BE SURE THAT PEOPLE ARE
FULLY EVALUATED AND I THINK
THAT CERTAINLY OF GOLD THIS
BILLS WELL WHICH I CLOSE. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER WHEN
I ASK FOR YOUR IPHONE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU IS THERE A
MOTION ON THIS BILL OF THE
BILL. OKAY I SEE OF. OKAY
CENTER TADAS THE BILL. RIGHT TO
THIS AGAIN THIS IS EIGHTY THREE
TWO FORTY TWO THE MOTION IS DO
PASS AMENDED AND RE REFER TO
THE SENATE RULES COMMITTEE IT'S
BEEN MOVED BY CENTER TADO.
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
PAN HI CAN I AND SALAS HI
GONZALEZ I GREW. FURTADO I THE
TITLE AYE LEYVA HI LEYVA AYE
MELENDEZ MITCHELL AYE MITCHELL
YEAH HI. RUBIO I. SEVEN ZERO
SEVEN THAT BILL IS OUT SEVEN
ZERO THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
FINALLY LET'S MOVE TO OUR
CONSENT CALENDAR WE HAVE SEVEN
ITEMS AND CONSENT AB THIRTY
EIGHTY SEVENTEEN TWENTY SEVEN
ITEM NUMBER ONE I AND NUMBER
SEVEN AB TWENTY ONE FIFTY SEVEN
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT EIGHTY TWENTY
ONE SIXTY FOUR ITEM NUMBER NINE
AB TWENTY TWO FIFTY THREE ITEM
NUMBER ELEVEN EIGHTY TWENTY
THREE HUNDRED ITEM NUMBER
THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO FOUR FIFTY
AN ITEM NUMBER FOURTEEN EIGHTY
TWENTY FIVE TWENTY IS MOTION SO
MOVED OKAY TENDED BY SENATOR
MITCHELL- SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. PAN HI CAN I CAN
SALAS HI THIS IS A LIST I GROW.
GROVE I HER TITLE NINE FOR
TOTAL AYE LEYVA HI LEAVE AYE
MELINDA'S MITCHELL. MITCHELL
AYE MONNING MONEY I RUBIO YOU
MADE IT. RUBIO HI RUBIO HI OKAY
ALL RIGHT CONSENT CALENDARS OUT
EIGHT ZERO ALRIGHT SO THIS
CONCLUDES THE AGENDA FOR THIS
HEARING OF THE SENATE COMMITTEE
COMMITTEE ON HEALTH I WANT TO
FIRST OF ALL I THINK ALL THE
INDIVIDUAL WHO PARTICIPATED IN
PUBLIC TESTIMONY TODAY IF YOU
ARE NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY TODAY
PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
COMMITTEE ON HEALTH OR VISIT
OUR WEBSITE YOUR COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT TO US
WE WANT INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY
IN THE OFFICIAL HEARING
RECORDS. THANK YOU I APPRECIATE
YOUR PARTICIPATION I WANT TO
THANK EVERYONE FOR THEIR
PATIENTS- WITH OUR- CHALLENGES
AT THE BEGINNING OF THE HEARING
PARTICULARLY ARE SLOWER
COMMITTEE STAFF- AND FOR STAFF
AND OUR COMMITTEE STAFF WORKED
VERY HARD TO. BE SURE WE HAD
THE BILL'S. AIR TODAY AND ALSO
WORKED VERY STAKEHOLDERS TO TRY
TO ACHIEVE OUR POLICY.
OBJECTIVES I ALSO WANT TO THANK
EVERYONE FOR YOUR PATIENCE
COOPERATION. AND WITH THAT-
THIS HEARING OF THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON HEALTH IS NOW